THE S. SENATE
COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE. IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVE IN NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC. AS WELL
AS LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING. AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO THIS HEARING ROOM. TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. AND WE WILL
BE USING TELECONFERENCE
SERVICES FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFIED TODAY.
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THAT THE
DISCIPLINE TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE. IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMTTEE WEBSITE. AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS ONE EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE FOUR ONE SEVEN SIX
ZERO NINE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO WORKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE ANDORRA ARE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL
BE PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO FOUR
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. PRESSES
ONLY ONE TIME. AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THIS
COULD BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL
BE ON MUTED. AND YOU ARE NOW
READY TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE. MAYBE THEY MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINED HEARING PROCESS AND
CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE
TO THE MATTER AS IS CUSTOMARY.
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOUR
TOOLS OR TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT TO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES. SO THEY CAN
BE HEARD. WE HAVE FIVE BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA WITH ONE BILL ON
CONSENT THAT'S S. B. THREE OH
FIVE FIVE SENATOR JOHN. BEFORE
WE HEAR PRESENTATIONS ON THE
BILL'S LET'S DOUBLE CHECK
QUORUM ASKAR COMMITTEE
CONSULTANT TO PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. OKAY OKAY- PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT THE YOUR MICROPHONE
IS ON AND SPEAK CLEARLY INTO
THE MIKE GLAZER PRESENT GLAZER
PRESENT NIELSEN. HERTZBERG
LEYVA HERE LEYVA HERE NEWMAN
HERE HUMAN HERE. YOU HAVE A
QUORUM I WOULD NOTE THAT IT IS
MY PRACTICE AND IT IS CUSTOMARY
TO BEGIN HEARING AFTER BOTH
PARTIES ARE REPRESENTED WE DID
CHECK WITH SENATOR NIELSEN'S
OFFICE AND HE HAS INDICATED
THAT HE'S COMFORTABLE WITH US
PROCEEDING WHILE HE- WE WAITED
AS A TEN. THEY HAVE AREAS
CENTER NIELSEN WELCOME. WHAT
WE'RE FIRST GOING TO START WITH
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE
ONE BILL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR SB THREE OH FIVE BY
JONES SO MOVED AS ANYBODY
OBJECTING TO- THERE THE
CONSECUTIVE OKAY SENILE
OBJECTIONS TO WHAT'S ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SAYING CENTER
LEYVA HAS MOVED THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. WITH THAT OF THE
COMMITTEE CONSOLE WOULD TAKE
THE ROLE. RIGHT ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR GLAZER. HI GLAZER AYE
NIELSEN AYE. NIELSEN AYE
HERTZBERG LEYVA HI LEYVA HI
NEWMAN HI NEWMAN I ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA PUT THAT BILL ON
CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WE ALSO
HAVE OUR COMMITTEE RULES THAT-
ARE PRESENTED TO ALL OF US
TODAY IT'S OUR FIRST MEETING OF
THE YEAR- AND I'M GONNA. ASK BY
ACCLAMATION IF THERE'S A GREEN
WITH THE COMMITTEE RULES I WANT
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY WISH
TO DISCUSS ANYTHING IN REGARD
TO THE RULES BEFORE WE DO. THE
CENTER NIELSEN. THE SHERMAN I'M
GONNA OF STAYING ON THE RULES I
DISLIKE THE LIMITATION OF THE-
DEBATE- YOUR THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR PUBLIC INPUT TO BE
RESTRICTED TO JUST NAME AND-
THAT'S ALL. THANK YOU CENTER
HILL AND NIELSEN AND I WILL AS
CHAIR DO MY BEST TO TRY TO
INCORPORATE AS MUCH INPUT AS WE
CAN'T THROUGHOUT THE COURSE OF
OUR HEARING I APPRECIATE THE
CONCERNS THAT YOU RAISE THEIR
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION THEN- WITH
SENATOR NIELSEN OF STANDING
WITH THE RULES SHALL BE.
ADOPTED. ALL RIGHT WE'D LIKE TO
WELCOME TO THE COMMITTEE
SENATOR BACKER. WELCOME CENTER
BACKER YOU HAVE TWO BILLS ON
FILE- TO BE HEARD TODAY SB FIVE
OH THREE AND SB FIVE OH FOUR.
YOU CAN PRESENT TO YOUR BILLS
LET'S BEGIN WITH SB FIVE OH
THREE. AND TO THOSE THAT
LISTENING AND PERHAPS FOR THE
FIRST TIME AFTER THE AUTHOR IS
PRESENTED. ON THIS CASE HIS
BILLS HIS BILL WE WILL HEAR
FROM HIS- MAIN WITNESSES IN
FAVOR- AND WE PROVIDE- TWO
WITNESSES OPPORTUNITIES THEY'RE
ASKING THEM TO LIMIT THE
REMARKS TO TWO MINUTES EACH-
AND THEN WE'LL HEAR FROM
SUPPORTERS SAID VIA. HEREIN
COMMITTEE ON THE PHONE LINES
AND THEN WE'LL DO THE SAME FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION.
SENATOR DR WELCOME. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR SHARE AND
MEMBERS. SB FIVE A THREE IS ALL
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY. IN
QUALIFYING BUT WE KNOW WORK
FROM THE REMEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION. IN LOSS TO
PRESIDENTIAL CYCLES ARE STATUS
GONE FROM LESS THAN 60% VOTING
BY MAIL TO ME 87% VOTING BY NOW.
THE PERSON OVER TWENTY TWENTY
ELECTION YOU KNOW CLEAR
STATEWIDE STANDARDS FOR VALUE
ANY SIGNATURES. IN A REPORT
PUBLISHED LAST SPRING STUDENTS
A STANFORD LAW IDENTIFIED
SIGNIFICANT DISPARITIES FROM
COUNTY TO COUNTY AND HOW THEY
EVALUATE SIGNATURES AND CURED
CHALLENGE MAIL ABOUT. NUMBER
PROJECTED MAIL IN BALLOTS TO
PASS A HUNDRED THOUSAND IN THE
MARCH TWENTY TWENTY PRIMARY
ABOUT ONE POINT 5% THE BALLOT.
THE SECULAR STATE ISSUED
EMERGENCY REGULATIONS TO
STANDARDIZE SIGNATURE
VERIFICATION. BUT WAS FOR THE
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY JIM
ELECTION ONLY. AND WHAT ABOUT
REJECTION RATE MARKEDLY
DECLINED THE REMAINS ARE
SCHEDULE VARIABILITY ACROSS
COUNTY LINES. TO SB FIVE OH
THREE CODIFIES WE LEARNED FROM
TWENTY TWENTY ENSURES A
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE
REGION THE SAME UNIFORM
PRACTICES. FOR SIGNATURE
ASSESSMENT AND REPORTING
REJECTIONS. JOHN SIGNATURES
DISPROPORTIONATELY PACKED MOST
REBEL KIND OF THE MOST
WONDERFUL CALIFORNIANS. THOSE
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENCY
DISABILITIES FIRST TIME VOTERS
AGING VOTERS. AND VOTERS OF
COLOR. SB FIVE A THREE GIVES
CONFIDENCE TO ALL CALIFORNIANS
THAT THEIR VOTES ARE COUNTED. I
THINK THE CHAIR THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE THOUGHTFUL
ANALYSIS I COMMIT TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE CHAIR AND
STAFF A BETTER CLARIFYING THE
STANDARD FOR SIGNATURE
VERIFICATION. AS SUGGESTED ON
PAGE EIGHT THE COMMITTEE NOW
SAYS. ALEX ARE EXPECT TO ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE WHEN SB FIVE OH
THREE. I WON WITH MISTER
CHARICE BY ON THE PHONE TO TEST
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
EDITION FOR SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
ON SIGNIFICANT SIGNATURE
VERIFICATION PROCESS SEES. I'VE
RUN RONCO PLASTER COUNTY CLERK
ALSO STANDING BY. RIFIC THANK
YOU SENATOR DECKER SO WE'LL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES TO HEAR FROM
YOUR LEAD A SUPPORT WITNESS
ERIC HARRIS. OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE- WELCOMED ERIC HARRIS TO
OUR OUR HEARING. IF YOU ARE
ONLINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I DO
NOT SEE HIM AT THIS TIME IF YOU
DO NOT HAVE AN OPEN LINE YOU
COMPRESS R. ONE AND THEN. ZERO
ONE MOMENT. MISTER HARRIS YOUR
MIND OPEN. YES HELLO THIS IS
ERIC HARRIS CAN YOU HEAR ME WE
CANISTER HARRIS PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MY NAME IS
ERIC HARRIS AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC POLICY AT
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR HAVE LETTING YOU
SPEAK THIS MORNING. SB FIFTY
FIVE OH THREE SETS OUT COMMON
SENSE REQUIREMENTS FOR
SIGNATURE VERIFICATION THAT ARE
GOOD FOR ALL VOTERS AND
CODIFIES MANY OF THE BEST
PRACTICES. IN THE SECRETARY OF
STATE CURRENT REGULATIONS FOR
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS FONG
COMPARING SIGNATURES. VOTERS
WITH DISABILITIES ARE MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE THEIR SIGNATURES
REJECTED. DUE TO MISMATCHES.
BECAUSE VOTERS WITHDISABILITIES. INST HAVE
SIGNATURES THAT CANGE OVER
TIME FOR STRUGGLE TO CREATE A
SEEMINGLY IDENTICAL SIGNATURE.
IN ADDITION TO VOTERS WITH
DISABILITIES AGING VOTERS AND
FIRST TIME VOTERS WILL BENEFIT
FROM SB FIVE OH THREE. THIS
BILL ESTABLISHES THAT AN EXACT
MATCH IS NOT REQUIRED AND
CREATES A PRESUMPTION THAT THE
SIGNATURE IS THE VOTERS. THE
BILL ALSO REQUIRES THE
REVIEWERS SHE USED THE
REGULATIONS AND THESE
REGULATIONS OVERALL ARE VERY
pINTERESTS OF THE VOTERS IN MY-
VOTING RIGHTS ADVOCATES
INCLUDING DRC RECOMMEND
COMMENTED. ON THE DRAFT
REGULATIONS THAT AND WE'RE
PLEASED WITH THE OUTCOME. THESE
REGULATIONS ALLOW SIGNATURE
REVIEWERS HAVE DIRECTLY TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT WHETHER A
DISABILITY HAVE IMPACTED THE
VOTER SIGNATURE AND OTHER
FACTORS LIKE TREMBLING AND
SHAKING. OVERALL THIS BILL IS
GOOD FOR VOTERS WITH
DISABILITIES. ANOTHER BENEFIT
OF THIS BILL IS THAT IT
EMPOWERS COUNTY ELECT COUNTY
ELECTION OFFICIALS TO BETTER
REACH OUT TO VOTERS WITH
MISMATCHED SIGNATURES.
CURRENTLY VOTERS ARE MAILED THE
NOTICE THAT THEIR SIGNATURES
MISMATCHED OR MISSING OR
MISSING. THIS IS GOOD BUT- BUT
MAIL IS NOT THE ONLY WAY TO
REACH OUT TO THE SUPPORTERS OF
DISABILITY. THIS BILL ALLOWS
COUNTY ELECTION OFFICIALS TO
USE OTHER FORMS IN A VOTERS
FILED NEXT TO CONTACT THEM. A
PHONE CALL OR AN EMAIL IS MUCH
MORE LIKELY TO REACH VOTERS
WITH DISABILITIES. AGAIN THIS
BILL WOULD BE VERY GOOD FOR ALL
VOTERS ESPECIALLY VOTERS WITH
DISABILITIES AND CREWS UP THE
VOTING AND CREWS WORKED FOR ALL.
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR THANK
YOU TO THE CHAIR AND THANK YOU
TO ALL THE MEMBERS. OF THIS
COMMITTEE PLEASE WELL I ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I MISTER HARRIS WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO FOR A LOOK FOR
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL HERE I THE CAPITAL
AS WELL AS ON THE PHONE LINES.
THREE ONE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM THAT WERE AND WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO TO A REMOTE
FACILITY HERE IN THE CAPITAL TO
SEE IF ANYONE IS HERE WILLING
TO. ATTACK ANOTHER INTO ROOMS
ARE THIS IS THE ONLY ROOM WHERE
WE HAVE WITNESSES IN THE
CAPITAL THAT RIGHT. JUST HERE
OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO TO THE
PHONE LINES. LET ME REMIND
PEOPLE THAT AFTER A LEAD
WITNESSES HAVE TESTIFIED WE ASK
THAT YOU ONLY. PROVIDE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION AND
WHETHER YOU ARE AGREE OR
DISAGREE WITH THE BILL THAT'S
BEFORE US. IN THIS CASE- WE'RE
GONNA ASK FOR SUPPORTERS TO SO
INDICATE SO LET'S GO TO OUR
PHONE LINES OPERATOR IF YOU
ASK. ANY INDIVIDUALS- WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
OH THREE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND
THEN ZERO NOW. ONE ZERO IF YOU
AREN'T SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE NO
RESULTS IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
VERY GOOD OPERATOR WOULD YOU
MAY DO A LAST AND FINAL CALL
FOR ANY WITNESSES WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE OH THREE TO PLEASE SO
INDICATE. ONE LAST FINAL CALL.
THANK YOU IF YOU AREN'T SUPPORT
AT SB FIVE ALL THREE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE. NINE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE AND THEN ZERO ONE
MOMENT PLEASE. WE DO HAVE ONE
COMING IN ONE MOMENT. AND
THAT'LL COME FROM LINE OF
SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES HELLO CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS BECAUSE JONATHAN VALLEY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION AND A PART OF SB
FIVE OH THREE- WE JUST FEEL
THAT. THIS IS A SIGNATURE MATCH
REQUIREMENT IN ADDITIONAL
UNNECESSARY BACK. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JUST- JUST
A REMINDER WERE JUST NAMED
AFFILIATION AND EDUCATION
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CALLING IN WE APPRECIATE IT.
VERY MUCH OPERATOR THERE ANY
OTHER. FOLKS WHO WANT TO TEST
OF IT'S A OF S. B. WITH. IN
SUPPORT IF YOU'D LIKE TO HAVE
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO NOW. ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
ANY SUPPORT. AND WE HAVE NO
SUPPORTING QUEUE AT THIS OKAY
TERRIFIC THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH WE'RE GONNA NOW MOVES TO
OPPONENTS OF THIS LEGISLATION I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE A AN
OPPONENT THAT HAS BEEN. AS A
LEAD OPPONENT- MISS RUTH WEISS
WITH THE ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT CALIFORNIA IS ON THE
LINE COULD YOU OPEN UP THIS
WEISS'S LINE PLEASE SO SHE CAN
PROVIDE TESTIMONY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN CAN YOU HEAR ME
I CAN'T PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY
THANK YOU WHEN AB EIGHT SIXTY
WITH PASSED GUARANTEEING THAT
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS TO DIRECTED TO SEE
THREE LOCATED ARE DUPLICATE
RECIPIENTS WOULD FLOOD THE
STATE. VOTERS ASK FOR
REASSURANCE THAT THEIR VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOT WOULD BE STAY FROM
NEUTRALIZATION BY
ILLEGITIMATELY CAST BALLOTS AND
THE SECRETARY OF STATE ISSUE
VERY HIGHLY PUBLICIZED
REASSURANCES. CITING THE
STATE'S CARDS SUCH AS
WATERMARKING A BALLOT IN
VIGOROUS SIGNATURE VERIFICATION
AFTER BUT THEN ON SEPTEMBER
EIGHTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY AFFECT
STATE HANDED DOWN EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS FOR THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION HAVING TO DO WITH
PROCESSING A VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOT. AND CONTRARY TO THE
STATE GUARDS PROMISED TO THE
PUBLIC THE EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS REQUIRED ACCEPTANCE
OF NO CARD BALANCE. MULTIPLE
BALLOTS STUFFED INTO A SINGLE
ENVELOPE AND THEY ALSO PROVIDED
LOOPHOLES FOR VIRTUALLY ALL
SIGNATURES TO BE ACCEPTED
MAKING EFFORT THAT LEGITIMATE
SIGNATURE VERIFICATION- MAYOR
SAM OF THESE REGULATIONS DID
NOT PROTECT LEGITIMATE BALLOTS
BUT RATHER THE ILLEGITIMATE
ONE. LAWFUL BALLOTS ALREADY
ENJOY SIGNIFICANT PROTECTION
WHEN CURRENT LAW IS APPLIED
ELECTIONS CODE THREE THOUSAND
MANDATE THAT VOTE BY MAIL
SIGNATURES BE LIBERALLY
CONSTRUED IN FAVOR OF THE VOTER
LIST PROVIDE GENEROUSLY WAY FOR
VOTER ERROR. CURRENT CALIFORNIA
LAW ALSO MANDATES THAT NO
SIGNATURE AND THEREFORE IF THE
COMPANY BALLOT CAN BE REJECTED
WITHOUT FIRST CONTACTING THE
VOTER AND OFFERING AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SECURE THE
SIGNATURE AND WE WOULD SUPPORT
EXPANSION OF THE WAY IN WHICH
THOSE VOTERS ARE CONTACTED. BUT
THE CURING PROCESS PROTECT
VOTERS WHOSE SIGNATURE HAS
GENUINELY CHANGED ANSWERED BACK
WHO FIND CARELESSLY AS A RESULT
IN THE CURRENT SAYS THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROVIDING
SIGNATURE BUT IT ALSO COULD
ALLEGE THE FISH LIVE. OR
SCRUTINY WITHOUT OF DISTANT
FRANCHISING LEGITIMATE VOTERS
ARE STRICT AND UNIFICATION OF
SIGNATURE. MATCHES VITAL TO
ALLEGE AND- BECAUSE ABOUT FIVE
VOTERS HAVE THE PER. OF THE
VERY CHARING CROSS. MORE A
SHOULD THE NEXT BE CHAO. NOT
SHE- SO SB FIVE A WOULD BRING
PERMIT MINISTRY FOR THE ABOVE
PROTECT. BY QATAR. A POOR OF
THE EMERGE RIGHT. AND RATIFY
THE RAFT SB OH THREE HI
THINKING OF A LECTURE OFFICIAL
IN. THAT BALLOT CAST BY. VOTER
WILL BE. SB FIVE OKAY ALSO A
BLANK CHECK OF P. POWER THE
SECOND OF STATE I REQUIRED
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS QUOTE HERE
ALL GLOBAL REGULATIONS PROBLEM
BY THE- OF STATE QUOTE. HOWEVER
ON CON. THERE OR HOW IT. TO AND
OF ELECTION THEY BE LOW VOTER
OF CALIFORNIA MUCH BETTER YEAH.
YEAH- JUST AND NOBLE ON SB FIVE
OH THREE THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISS WHY YOUR TEST. WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO OTHER WITNESSES
WHO WOULD LIKE TO- IT PUT ON
THE RECORD OFFICE TO THIS LET-
IS THERE ANY HERE AND THIRTY
ONE NINETY THAT WE SPEAK. AND
UP. RIGHT C. NINE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR WOULD
YOU ASK THAT ANYONE WOULD LIKE
TO GIVE THEIR OUT THEIR NAME
AND AFFILIATION IN THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE SP FIVE OH
THREE TO PLEASE SO INDICATE.
THANK YOU IF YOU'RE NOT THE
VISION. MY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
NOW. ONE MOMENT. OUR FIRST
FINAL COME FROM MY TWENTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME
IS SHARON WASHINGTON I'M A
WOMAN OF COLOR AND I AM AGAINST
THIS BILL IT CREATES MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR FRAUD I I'M
SHOCKED THAT THIS IS HAPPENING
YOU'RE LOOKING THEM OR- YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR CALLING IN AND
SHARING YOUR THOUGHTS. IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
OPPORTUNITY GO TO THE NEXT
CALLER IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
THAT'LL COME FROM MINE TWENTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS JEFF PASSION
NINE- PRIVATE INDIVIDUAL IN
STOCKTON. I WOULD- BUT POST
SENATE BILL FIVE OH THREE- THE
SENATE BILL FIVE A THREE N. AND
SERVICE PUTTING WE'RE JUST
PUTTING OUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION IN YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL IN THE RECORD NOW
THERE'S ALREADY BEEN TESTIMONY
AGAINST. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CALLING. I PREFER TO GO TO THE
NEXT CALL THE POLICE. YES THANK
YOU ONE TWENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO AND THE PRESIDENT
INDIVIDUAL JENNIFER JOHNSON AND
I OPPOSE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
CALLING IT OPERATOR NEXT. THANK
YOU LINE FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THIS IS AMY CHAU
ELECTION INTEGRITY AND RESIDENT
OF PLASTER COUNTY AYE OPPOSED
THIS SB FIVE OH THREE THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR CALLING IN OPERATOR
NEXT. THANK YOU THEY'LL COME
FROM LINE OF FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
ZERO CLIENT THERE IS A NINETY
NINE AND- CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE.
SB FIVE OH THREE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR CALLING AT OPERATOR
NEXT. THANK YOU THAT'LL COME
FROM LINE TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH MY NAME IS
LINDA ANDERSON A CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT I OPPOSE SB FIVE OH
THREE THANK YOU SO MUCH NEXT.
THANK YOU KNOW COME FROM ONE
THIRTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES MY NAME IS KATHERINE WARNER
I'M FROM SANTA CLARA COUNTY AND
I'M WITH THE ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT OF CALIFORNIA AND I AM
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR CALLING AN OPERATOR
HOW MANY- CALLERS TO HAVING Q.
WE HAVE TWENTY. K. OPERATOR
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU THAT'LL
COME FROM LINE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WHY TWENTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
WE'LL GO ON TO THE NEXT ONE OF
LINE FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS SUSAN KENNEDY SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND I OPPOSE- FIVE
OH THREE. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE OPERATOR. THANK YOU
THEIR COMPROMISED SIXTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
GEORGIA RIGHT IN LINE WITH
SOLANO COUNTY CENTRAL COMMITTEE
AND I OPPOSE FIVE OH THREE.
THANK YOU FOR CALLING AN
OPERATOR NEXT. THANK YOU HAVE A
COME FROM LINE SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS JAMES
YOU'RE ON CALLING FROM SANTA
CLARA COUNTY SUNNYVALE- IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR CALLING OPERATOR NEXT.
THANK YOU HAVE A COMPROMISED
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NANCY RADER RIVERSIDE COUNTY
OPPOSE FIVE OH THREE. THANK YOU
FOR CALLING OPERATOR NEXT.
THANK YOU THAT A COMBINED
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
MY NAME IS CHRIS FOSTER I
REPRESENT MYSELF I'M FROM
ORANGE COUNTY AND I OPPOSE SB
FIVE OH THREE. THANK YOU CHRIS
FOR CALLING AN OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU THEIR
COME FROM LINE SEVENTY THREE
JOHN LOPEZ. ALFIE WITH ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT AYE OPPOSED
SB FIVE ZERO THREE. THANK YOU
MISS LOPEZ CALLED THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU THEIR
COMBINED NET SIXTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES HELLO MY NAME
IS PATRICIA MICHELE- THE
RETIRED PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER
FROM CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN
DEFINITE OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL FIVE OH THREE THANK YOU
PATRICIA OPERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THAT A COME FROM MY
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS DIANE JONES ST IN
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND I OPPOSE
SB FIVE OH THREE THANK YOU FOR
CALLING AN OPERATOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU THAT'LL COME
FROM LINE SIXTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. A GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
STEVE CHAU I'M FROM PLASTER
COUNTY AND I'M FAMILIAR WITH-
ELECTION INTEGRITY AND I AM
OPPOSED TO FIVE ALL THREE.
THANK YOU STEVE OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THAT A
COMPROMISE THIRTY THREE YOUR
IS WHEN KERR BROUGHT US IS IN A
VENTURA COUNTY- I OPPOSE SENATE
BILL FIVE OH THREE THANK YOU
MISTER ROBOT OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. BETTER COME FROM
LINE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT ONE IN LINE FIFTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
NANCY MADSEN AND THAT AN
INDIVIDUAL AND I OPPOSE SB FIVE
OH THREE THANK YOU MISS MATSON
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND THAT'LL COME FROM NINE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS ROBIN BIT SEN WHAT WE
THE PEOPLE RISING I STRONGLY
OPPOSE WE NEED VOTER I THANK
YOU ROBIN. NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THANK YOU. WELCOME TO A LINE OF
FIFTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS MARY ELLEN ELITE THANK
YOU LAW SAN MATEO COUNTY
STRENUOUSLY OPPOSED. FIVE OH
THREE THANK YOU MARY ALLEN NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
AMERICAN FROM LINE FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WAYNE BIGGER
ORANGE COUNTY OPPOSE SB FIVE
AGREE THANK YOU MISTER THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND THAT'LL COME
FROM NINE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS SHERRY
MCKAY FROM CARMICHAEL
SACRAMENTO COUNTY I AM AN
INDIVIDUAL AND I OPPOSE. SB
FIVE OH THREE THANK YOU MISS
MCKAY. NEXT CALLER PLEASE
OPERATOR. THAT'LL COME FROM
NINE THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO OF PETITIONS
CORNEIL HO I'M CALLING FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND I OPPOSE SB
FIVE OH THREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR CALLING AN OPERATOR HOW
MANY CALLERS TO BE NOW HAVING
Q. WE HAVE. THREE LEFT IN Q.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
AND THAT'LL COME FROM LINE
THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS KIM EMERSON- IN PLASTER
COUNTY IN THE ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT I PUT THAT
DOWN THANK YOU FOR CALLING IN-
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU KNOW COME FROM LINE
OF EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO YES YES PLEASE PROCEED.
WE CAN HEAR YOU YES MY NAME IS
BRENDA CAMPBELL I'M CALLING FOR
MEMBERS COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB FIVE OH THREE THANK
YOU MISS CAMPBELL NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU I FUNDING
QUEUE COMES FROM LINE OF SIXTY
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. REPORTER
FROM ALAMEDA COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE SB FIVE WITH WORK THANK
YOU FOR CALLING IT NEXT CALLER
PLEASE- WE DO HAVE ONE MORE IN
Q. LET ME GET THEIR NUMBER ONE
MOMENT MISTER. FOR AND THAT'LL
COME FROM ONE OF TWENTY FOUR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
TERREL BELL SENT FROM THE
PLASTER COUNTY CENTRAL
COMMITTEE AYE OPPOSED SB FIVE
OH THREE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR CALLING IN MODERATE KEY
CHECK THE LINES ONCE AGAIN TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO SB FIVE OH THREE. LAST AND
FINAL CALL. YES PROPOSITION.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE ZERO PROPOSITIONS OF SB
FIVE ALL. THREE AND WE HAVE.
TWELVE MORE IN Q. OKAY PLEASE
PUT IN ORDER THE FIRST FINE
OKAY OF OUR TWENTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
LEONARD PERRA I AM A LEGAL
DIFFERENT IMMIGRANT IN SAN
DIEGO CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB FIVE OR THREE IN THE
TRONG IT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
THAT'LL COME FROM ONE THIRTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
MY NAME IS JANELLE QUAN I'M AT
THE DISTANCE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB FIVE OH THREE THANK
YOU GIONALE NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU BETTER COME FROM WIND
OF EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI HELLO YEAH MY NAME IS
NANCY GIRL OF THE NIGHT
ADAMANTLY OPPOSED SB FIVE OH
THREE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THAT ARE
COMPROMISED OF SIXTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY YES EMIR'S
JANICE DUPORT AND I AM FROM A
PLASTER COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK YOU FOR
CALLING IT NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU MALCOLM FROM LINE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS CAROLYN
CENTER I AM A MEMBER OF THE
ELECTION INTEGRITY GROUP AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB FIVE OH
THREE. THANK YOU FOR CALLING
IN. OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE
THANK YOU. AND THE NEXT ONE
WILL COME FROM ONE EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS THE ULTIMATE SOURCE
I'M A REGISTERED VOTER IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE. BY BOTH THREE AND BE
ABLE TO PRINT THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING. TODAY OPERATOR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU HAVE
COME FROM LINE SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS REJECTED THE ALI WITH
PLASTER COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB FIVE OH THREE THANK
YOU FOR CALLING THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE OPERATOR. AND THAT'LL
COME FROM LIKE SEVENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS PAM BRADFORD I'M IN EL
DORADO COUNTY AND I AM A MEMBER
OF ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT.
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB FIVE
OR THREE THANK YOU FOR CALLING
IN NEXT CALLER PLEASE OPERATOR.
THANK YOU HAVE COME FROM LINE
OF SEVENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE JOHN LOPEZ. I
ALREADY. OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE
GOODNESS HONEST THANK YOU AND
I'LL COME FROM LINE OF THE
SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NINE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IF THAT'S NAY YEAH MY
NAME STAFF TO PASS YEAH. TIME
FOR YOUR COMMENT MEMBER OF
ELECTION PROJECT I AM STRONGLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU AND THE LAST ONE IN
Q. WILL COME FROM A LINE OF
THIRTY FIVE. YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS LINDA HEALTH PLAN
I'M A VOTING. IN SARATOGA
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB FIVE OH THREE THANK
YOU FOR CALLING AN OPERATOR ANY
OTHER- INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. ONE MORE
CUED UP ONE MOMENT. AND AS A
REMINDER TO ONE AND THEN ZERO
OPPOSITION. AND THEN THAT ONE
WILL COME FROM NINE THIRTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES I AM
CHRISTY ST- CALIFORNIA
REGISTERED VOTER AND I OPPOSE
SB FIVE OH THREE. GOOD
OPERATORS THAT TO CONCLUDE THE
TESTIMONY THAT YOU CAN SEE.
THAT DOES CONCLUDE THE
TESTIMONY TO RECYCLE I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE FOLKS WHO-
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION TO THIS LEGISLATION
THAT'S BEFORE US WE'RE GONNA
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
FOR COMMENTS OR- QUESTIONS
COLLEAGUES ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. I HAVE SENATOR
NEWMAN I HAVE CENTER NIELSEN
SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRED AND- CHEN
REBEKAH GOOD SHE SEEMS LIKE THE
LEAST WE COULD DOES PROVIDE YOU
WITH A PODIUM THIS MORNING- I.
WANTED LETTERING. THIS YEAR
EIGHT ANY LEGITIMATE EFFORT TO
DETERMINE A BALLOTS LEGITIMACY
IN WOULD PUT INDISCRIMINATE AND
UNRESTRICTED POWER TO THE HANDS
OF A SINGLE. ELECTED OFFICIAL-
THE MANDATES ARE ANTITHETICAL
TO DESTRUCTIVE OF ELECTION
INTEGRITY. I OBVIOUSLY DON'T
BELIEVE THAT BUT I'D LIKE TO
GIVE YOU A CHANCE TO SPEAK TO
THE RECORD- THAT'S A BROAD AND-
VERY STRONG STATEMENT IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND RESPONDING. SURE
THANK YOU CENTER NEWMAN. GET
THIS KIND OF PRICE WE LEARNED
WORKS IN THAT TWENTY TWENTY
THIS IS ALL ABOUT TRANSPARENCY.
FOR EXAMPLE PROVISIONS OF THE
BALLOT THE BILL. RIGHT INSURE
THAT CIRCULAR STATE PUBLISHED
TIMELY REJECTED MAIL BALLOT
REPORTS SAID CONSISTENT
REJECTED BALLOT REASONS
CULTURAL COUNTY TO REPORT ON
THIS ACTUALLY WILL INCREASE THE
TRANSPARENCY SO WE CAN SEE WHAT
IS HAPPENING ALEXION SYSTEM. HI
IT'S PREPAID ENVELOPES FOR
CHALLENGING RETURNING CHALLENGE
BALLOT AFFIDAVITS THAT'S THE
LAST STEP IN OUR PROCESS WHERE
PEOPLE NOW HAVE TO GO. FIND IT
CAN'T DO IT THEMSELVES AND THEN
AND TO ELIMINATE THAT FRICTION
IS WE ACTUALLY INCREASED
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN. THE THAT
THE REGISTER TO COUNTIES AND
THE INDIVIDUALS. WE LAY OUT OF
THE COUNTY OFFICES MAY ISSUE
TWO OR MORE. APRIL ELECTRIC
NOTIFICATION NOTICES NOTICES
ARE AFFIDAVITS FOR CHALLENGE
BALLOTS TO VOTERS ANY USE
DIFFERENT MODES OF CONTACTS
ELECTRONIC AS WE HEARD FROM
THE- WITNESS IN SUPPORT- ON
THE- TO CALL FOUR TWO EMAIL
ANYWAY SO THIS IS REALLY ALL
ABOUT ENCOURAGING TRANSPARENCY.
AND IT IS CLEAR THAT STAT THAT
CHANGED FROM MATCH WE DON'T
KNOW WE ALL SURGERY CHANGE OVER
TIME FOR MATCH TO COMPARE. AND
AGAIN THIS IS ALL THE SPIRIT OF
WHAT WE LEARNED IN TWENTY
TWENTY AFTER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
BALLOTS WERE REJECTED. I
APPRECIATE THAT SIR IN JUST BE
CLEAR AND IT IT'S SORT OF
INHERENT IN THIS PROCESS. TO
THE EXTENT THAT COUNTIES RUN
ELECTIONS IN CALIFORNIA- THE
LEGISLATURE C. DELEGATES
SIGNIFICAN RESPONSIBILITIES TO
REGISTRATION AND THE STAFF BUT
IT I DID. IT IS CLEAR I THINK
AS YOU'VE MADE. A BY REMARKS
WERE NOT ABDICATING ANY
RESPONSIBILITY WERE SIMPLY
CLARIFYING AND DELEGATES. YES
AND AGAIN INCREASING THAT
TRANSPARENCY INCREASING THE
MODES OF COMMUNICATION THINK
THAT LIMITING THE FRICTION BY
PROVIDING THE PREPAID. ENVELOPE
IN TERMS OF- THAT THAT
CHALLENGE PROCESS SO REALLY
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY AND I TRYING
TO ELIMINATE. THE FRICTION AND
THEN GREATLY THE ASSUMPTION OF
THE CITRUS CORRECT AND THEN IF
THERE IS REASON TO CHALLENGE IT
THANK GOD WE CREATE THAT THAT
TRANSPARENCY AND ELIMINATE THAT
FRICTION. IN THAT COMMUNICATION
WITH THE VOTERS. THANK YOU MR.
THANK YOU SENATOR NEWMAN CENTER
NIELSEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'M GOING TO OPPOSED.
THE BILL OVER MANY YEARS WE
HAVE SEEN MANY MANY ATTEMPTS TO
DIMINISH THE VALIDITY OF THE
VOTER ID VERIFICATION. THIS IS
ANOTHER ONE THE SIGNATURE IS
NOT ALL THAT DIFFICULT TO
CONTEND WITH. AND I REJECT
THOSE WHO CHARGE THAT THOSE WHO
OPPOSE THESE KIND OF IDEAS ARE
DOING VOTER SUPPRESSION NOT
ABSOLUTELY REJECT THAT AND I'M
GLAD TO SEE THAT THERE ARE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
WHO ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE THE BALLOT
INTEGRITY AND IT DOES HAVE ITS
BEARING ON ELECTIONS. THANK YOU
SENATOR NIELSEN SENATOR
HERTZBERG. YEAH I WAS GONNA ASK
YOU A QUESTION BUT IT. I JUST
WANT TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS IN
THE LARGER CONTEXT OF WHAT THE
GOVERNMENT DOES IN
RELATIONSHIP. TO VALIDATING
SIGNATURES NOW IT YEAH MY
CORRECT TO ASSUME THAT I THINK
I'M CORRECT FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING- CENTER BECKER
THAT WHEN YOU SIGN YOUR SIGNING
INTO THE PENALTY OF PERJURY
CORRECT YES OKAY SO WHEN YOU
SIGN YOUR DRIVER'S LICENSE YOU
SIDE OF THE PENALTY O PERJURY
THAT'S THE LAW. WHEN YOU SIGNED
A DECLARATION BEFORE COURT YOU
SIDE UNDER THE PENALTY OF
PERJURY WHEN YOU SIGN EVERY
SINGLE DOCUMENT EXCEPT FOR
RECORDED DOCUMENT IN THE
REGISTRAR RECORDER'S DOCUMENT
THE TRANSFERS. TITLE TO
PROPERTY IT'S A SIGNATURE. AND
NOW THE QUESTION BECOMES. WHEN
YOU MAKE SUCH A STATEMENT WHICH
HAS CAUSED HUGE CONSEQUENCES TO
YOUR LIFE RIGHT IN EVERY
CONTEXT OF EVERY DOCUMENT IF
YOU'RE- TRYING TO APPLY FOR ANY
GOVERNMENT SERVICE YOU MAKE ANY
REPRESENTATION BUT FOR
RECORDING. YOU HAVE A SIGNATURE
SO THEN THE QUESTION BECOMES
AYE YOUR DRIVER'S LICENSE OR ON
THE- ANY OTHER APPLICATION FOR
ANYTHING ELSE YOU APPLY FOR
YOUR BUSINESS LICENSE ME IS A
LAWYER GOING TO APPLY TO. A
LICENSE TO PRACTICE LAW ORDERS
AND ARCHITECT. DOES IT MEAN
THAT THAT THEN AS A STANDARD
THE QUESTION IS WHAT'S THE
STANDARD. IN THE LAW WE'VE GOT
BASIC STANDARDS IF YOU'RE GOING
TO CONVICT SOMEBODY. OF MURDER
YOU GOT IT YOU KNOW YOU GOTTA
BE ABLE DO IT BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT THE QUESTION
IS. THE QUESTION IS THE
STANDARD HERE. IS BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT IS THE TO ME
THE BIGGER ISSUE AS WE EXAMINE
THIS WHETHER IT'S IN THE
ELECTION CONTEXT OR- ANY OTHER
KIND OF CONTEXT IN WHICH YOU
WERE ENGAGED. YOU ARE SIGNING
THE PENALTY OF PERJURY SO
THERE'S CONSEQUENCES AND THEN
THE QUESTION NOW IS WHO THE
VALIDATOR WHO LOOKS AT THE
SIGNATURE. THEY HAVE A STANDARD
OF BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT
THE QUESTION THAT I LOOK AT IN
THIS MEASURE. IS AS A SOCIETY
WHAT STANDARDS DO WE USE. UNDER
THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES WHETHER
IT'S A CRIMINAL PROCEEDING OR
CIVIL PROCEEDING. BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT SUBSTANDARD
BUT FOR CERTAIN VERY UNIQUE
FELONIES. WHEN YOU'RE
CONVICTING SOMEBODY SO TO ME.
NO DIFFERENCE THAN CODIFYING
WHAT IS THE UNDERLYING
JURISPRUDENTIAL BASIS FOR
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO AND IF
YOU WERE SOMEBODY VIOLATES THE
LAW IT WANTS TO SUFFER THE
CONSEQUENCES SO BE IT SO. WHEN
I LOOK AT THAT LARGER STANDARD
APOLOGIES FOR GOING ALONG WITH
IT JUST HITS ME LIKE A BRICK IN
TERMS OF LOOKING AT ALL OF THE
OTHER AREAS OF THE LAW IN WHICH
PEOPLE ARE INTERFACING WITH
THEIR GOVERNMENT. THIS JUST
SIMPLY SETS A STANDARD
CONSISTENT WITH. THAT
JURISPRUDENTIAL PRACTICE SO I
JUST WANTED TO UNLESS YOU THINK
I'M WRONG IN TERMS OF DOING
MORE HOMEWORK ON THIS. I LOOK
AT THIS AND I DON'T SEE
ANYTHING. OTHER THAN THAT IT
AND WHY SHOULD THE STANDARD BE
ANYTHING DIFFERENT THAN ANY
OTHER STANDARD ESPECIALLY THE
CRIMINAL CONTEXT ANOTHER
CONTEXT. PLEASE ONE AT IT
UNLESS YOU THINK I'M WRONG-
CENTER BECKER I JUST WANT TO
SHARE THOSE THOSE THINKING THAT
THINKING HERE. YES NO I
APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS AND
AGREE WITH THEM AND I
APPRECIATE THAT CENTER
HERTZBERG. IS THERE A NIELSEN I
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS AS
WELL- YOU KNOW WOULD KNOWN AS
ALLEGING VOTER SUPPRESSION IN
THOSE. BUT WHAT WE DISEASE WIDE
VARIATION BETWEEN THE COUNTIES
AND THAT'S BECAUSE IT WAS
REALLY UNCLEAR. AND THIS IS ALL
RELATIVELY NEW ESPECIALLY IN
TERMS OF THE DRAMATIC INCREASE.
IN MAIL IN BALLOTS SO I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR CONCERN
APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS RAISED-
BUT AGAIN THIS IS ALL ABOUT
REALLY INCREASING TRANSPARENCY
YES WE DO CHANGE THE
PRESUMPTION. AND CHANGE THAT
FROM MATCH TO COMPARE BUT IT'S
REALLY NOT INCREASING THAT
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN. THE
REGISTRAR AND THE INDIVIDUAL.
THEN PACKER THANK YOU. YOUR
WORK ON THIS LEGISLATION- WITH
MY STAFF AND WITH ME
APPRECIATED THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE HAD. AND I- I
APPRECIATE THE GOAL THAT YOU'VE
ESTABLISHED IN THIS BILL WE
WANT EVERY VOTE TO COUNT AT THE
END OF THE DAY THAT'S REALLY
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO ENSURE. A
HAPPENS AND I APPRECIATE THE
WORK FROM THE STUDENTS AT
STANFORD. AND LOOKING AT OUR
ELECTIONS IN THE PAST TO. SEE
WHETHER THAT'S HAPPENING AT AND
THAT'S THAT THAT'S BEEN THE
SPARK FOR. YOU WORK IN THIS
AREA. I KNOW THAT. YOU KNOW
WHEN I SIGNED MY DRIVER'S
LICENSE YOU KNOW. FIVE YEARS
AGO TEN YEARS AGO TWENTY YEARS
AGO OR VOTER REGISTRATION
APPLICATION THAT MY SIGNATURE
IS NOT THE SAME. AND THAT A LOT
OF US IN OUR DAILY LIFE. YOU
KNOW GET REMEMBER THOSE CURSE
OF COURSES AND SO WE'RE REALLY
CAREFUL ABOUT THOSE **** IN
THOSE JEEZ AND DISEASE IN MY
CASE- BUT CERTAINLY AS THOSE
LESSONS OF FATE IN OUR MEMORY.
PERHAPS WEEK WE MOVE A LITTLE
FASTER AND WRITING OUR NAME
AND- IT POSES CHALLENGES
BECAUSE THIS IS A HUMAN
INTERPRETATION. THIS ISN'T A
MACHINE INTERPRETATION AND
ALTHOUGH I UNDERSTAND SOME OF
THEM ARE USED TO. DO A QUICK
SCREEN ON SOME OF THE STUFF-
IT'S A IT'S A PERSON AND SO IT
IS IN IT BUT IT YOU KNOW AND
EVERY PERSON IN EVERY COUNTY
MIGHT. LOOK AT SOMETHING A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY AND SO I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE WHERE
YOU'RE GOING WITH US AND I
THINK THE EMERGENCY REGULATIONS
THAT WERE ISSUED. BY THE
SECRETARY OF STATE. A MERE MUCH
OF WHAT YOU ARE TRYING TO DO IN
THIS BILL. AND I THINK UP WITH
THE IDEA THAT WE WANT EVERY
VOTE TO COUNT AND THAT REALLY
HAS TO BE AT. A HIGHER.
THRESHOLD TO ELIMINATE
SOMEONE'S VOICE THAN THEIR
VOTE. I DO WANT TO ASK YOU
THOUGH TO SPEAK TO THIS ISSUE
OF BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT-
IT'S A STANDARD THAT- CAN BE
SUBJECT TO INTERPRETATION AND
SO CAN YOU SPEAK TO. WHAT YOU
THINK THAT MEANS AND WHAT THAT
COMMUNICATES TO OUR FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY REGISTRARS. YES WELL I
APPRECIATE THAT AND AGAIN I
APPRECIATE. IT YOU BET YOUR
GLAZER AND YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING- ON THEM THIS TO THIS
BILL- WITH US. IN PARTICULARLY
ON THIS APPOINTED AS I MENTION
OPENING STATEMENT. I WILL WORK
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOUR
STAFF PARTICULARLY ON THIS
POINT TO MAKE SURE. THAT IS
CLEAR. ON THAT AGAIN TO US
IT'S- WERE. YOU KNOW AGAIN IT'S
ABOUT TRANSPARENCY RUSSIA
CHANGING PRESUMPTION. THAT NONE
FROM THE PRESUMPTION THAT IT'S
REALLY INVALID TO PRESUMPTION
OF THE SIGNATURES VALID. AND
FOR THAT THEN TO FEEL LIKE
BEYOND REASONABLE DOUBT THAT-
THAT- THAT IT'S INVALID IN THAT
PROCESS THEN. OF CHALLENGING
THE SIGNATURE SO. THAT'S REALLY
WHAT IT'S ABOUT TO US IS KIND
OF CRAZY THAT LARGER THRESHOLD.
AND THIS IS THE PENLEE
PERJURIOUS CENTER HERTZBERG.
SAID ARE THAT ALL THAT ALREADY
APPLIES. SO THIS IS REALLY
ABOUT BEGIN CHANGING THAT THAT
PRESUMPTION. AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOUR
TEAM- FOR ANY CLARIFICATIONS ON
US. NOT CREATE THAT TO SENATOR
BECKER I DO THINK THAT THE-
STANDARDS THAT THE- EMERGENCY
ORDER. CREATED WHAT WE'RE A
LITTLE BIT MORE SPECIFIC MMHM-
IN TERMS OF DETERMINING THAT A
SIGNATURE- WAS IT WAS VALID. I
THINK THE PRESUMPTION OF COURSE
WOULD BE THERE AS WELL. SO I
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT THAT THAT
CONVERSATION AS THE BILL. GOES
FORWARD I WOULD NOTE THAT. WHEN
YOU LOOK AT- THIS IS THE
IMPORTANT BILL DON'T
MISUNDERSTAND ME BUT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE CONTEXT OF ALL
THOSE PEOPLE WHO VOTED IN. OUR
ELECTIONS. THAT THE PERCENTAGE
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET TO. IS
A FRACTION- A HALF OF ONE
PERCENT. NO THAT'S NOT
INSIGNIFICANT IT'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO
DO EVEN BETTER WHICH IS WHAT
THE GOAL OF YOUR BILL AS- BUT I
WOULD PUT IN CONTEXT THAT- THIS
IS NOT. ABOUT TO TAKE OVER OF
ELECTIONS OR WHATEVER ANYONE
WANTS TO CHARACTERIZE SOMEHOW.
THE ACTIONS OF THIS BILL- MIGHT
HAVE ANY ANY IMPACT- AND IN
DOING SO WITHOUT AYE I'LL SEE
IF THERE'S ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
COMMENTS SENATOR NIELSEN.
THURMOND THANK YOU FOR THAT TO
THE CONCERNED ABOUT BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT I'M VERY
FAMILIAR WITH THAT THRESHOLD.
IT CERTAINLY IS APPLICABLE TO
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR THERE IS A
LIBERTY INTEREST AT STAKE. BUT
IN THE CASE OF THESE.
INCIDENCES HERE OF SIGNATURES.
I DOUBT THERE ARE VERY MANY
PROSECUTIONS THAT ANY SECTOR
STAYS EVER FORWARDED TO AN
ATTORNEY GENERAL I'D LIKE TO
KNOW TE NUMBERS I'M SURE THERE
ARE MINUSCULE. AND THAT AND
THAT'S WHY I THINK THIS GOES A
BIT FAR SO I'D- APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORSHIP GOOD ACCEPTED
PHILLIES TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
VERY IMPORTANT VERY. OF BEYOND
A REASONABLE DOUBT. THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE VERY DIFFERENT
TO- FOR THAT TYPE OF BEHAVIOR
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH. VERY
GOOD AT COLLEAGUES ANYTHING
FURTHER I'M GONNA ASK THE
AUTHOR TO A CLOSE ON HIS BILL.
OKAY CENTER BACKER THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
DISCUSSION AND I WILL WE WILL
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT THAT AND
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
FURTHER CLARIFY- IN WITH THAT
DISCUSSION. AND THE NEEDED
STAKE IN THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
ISSUE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. RAIL HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL THE DAYS ARE MOTION
FROM THE COMMITTEE. I HEARD
SENATOR NEWMAN MOVING THE BILL.
AND WITH THAT IF TO CONSULT
WOULD CALL THE ROLL. THIS
SHOULD BE TO PASS- FIRST
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. YEAH FOR SB
THREE OH FIVE FIVE OH THREE SB
FIVE OH THREE. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
GLAZER HI LEESER HI NIELSEN NO
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT
FOR THIRD FIVE LEYVA FIVE LEYVA
AYE NEWMAN ALL RIGHT. NEWMAN
AYE WE HAVE A FULL COMMITTEE
THAT BILL IS OUT FOUR TO ONE
REGULATION CENTER BACKER YOU
HAVE A SECOND BILL TO PRESENT
TO US TODAY SB. FIVE OH FOUR.
YES I WAS FIRST BILL EVERNOTE
YEAH I WE ASK A HAVE MOTION FOR
RECONSIDERATION FROM CENTER
YEAH HERTZBERG. WELL WE CAN SEE
BULLET OTHER JAN THAT OTHER GOT
THE FLU YET SAN HERTZBERG SELF.
THIS IS A WALKING. ALL RIGHT
BAKER MAYBE THIS WILL I DO AS
WELL AS FIVE OH FOUR AND OUR
YEAH YEAH THE VISION OF POINT
BUT THANK YOU YES THIS IS OUR
FIRST I'VE THAT THING AND-
APPRECIATED GIVE MORE AGAIN-
AND MISTER CHAIR AND.
CALIFORNIA'S COUNTY TO SHOW
STRONG DESIRE TO FOR. JUSTICE
INVOLVED FORMALLY. VOTERS BUT
INCOMPLETE OR INACCURATE.
PLEASE ELECTION OFFICIALS
MAKING EDUCATED GUESSES AS A
TEMP TO KEEP VOTER REGISTRATION
RECORDS UP TO DATE.
ADDITIONALLY MILITARY AND
OVERSEAS VOTERS ARE CURRENTLY
PROHIBITED FROM UTILIZING SAME
DATE FOR CONDITIONAL VOTER
REGISTRATION OPTIONS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO VOTERS AND STATE.
FIFTEEN BOTH OF THESE REQUIRES
CHANGES TO THE VOTER
REGISTRATION PROCESS. SB FIVE
OH FOUR REQUIRES REGULAR
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN CDCR
UNDERSECRETARY OF STATE.
RECENTLY STREAMLINED PROCESSES
AND DATA FLOWS CAN IS REQUIRED
TO NOTIFY THOSE WHOSE VOTING
RIGHTS HAVE BEEN RESTORED. SB
FIVE BEFORE ALSO EXTENDS
EXISTING VOTER REGISTRATION
OPTIONS TO ALL VOTERS. WHETHER
IN STATE OR SERVING OVERSEAS
PERSONS SERVING IN OUR MILITARY.
I THANK THE CHAIR AND STAFF OF
THE CHILDREN PARTNERSHIP IN
ANALYSIS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU SENATOR BAKER I
UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE A LEAD
SUPPORT WITNESS- RYAN RONCO
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF CLERKS AND ELECTION
OFFICIALS. OPERATOR UNDERSTAND
AYE MR ROCCO IS ON THE LINE TO
TESTIFY IN FAVOR OF SB FIVE OH
FOUR YES THREE MINUTES WOULD
YOU ADVISE HIM TO BE YEAH. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GREAT THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING SURE GLAZER MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE CAN YOU HEAR
ME OK WE CAN HEAR YOU JUST FINE.
GREAT THANK YOU- I AM I RIGHT
GO BY THE COUNTY CLERK RECORDER
REGISTRAR OF VOTERS AND-
CULTURE OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS AND
ELECTION OFFICIALS LEGISLATION-
COMMITTEE. WE ARE PLEASED TO
SPONSOR SB FIVE OH FOUR AND I'D
LIKE THANK GOD CENTER BACKER
AND HIS- GREAT STAFF FOR THEIR
IMPORTANT WORK ON THIS BILL. SB
FIVE OH FOUR SEEKS TO FIX THE
DESIGN FLAW IN CURRENT LAW WITH
RESPECT TO CONDITIONAL VOTER
REGISTRATION. RIGHT NOW
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
REQUIRES THE PERSON WISHING TO
REGISTER AND VOTE FOURTEEN DAYS
BEFORE ELECTION DAY THROUGH
ELECTION DAY. TO BE PHYSICALLY
PRESENT TOGETHER AT THE OFFICE
OF THE ELECTIONS OFFICIAL OR AT
A POLLING PLACE TO VOTE CENTER.
IN ORDER TO REGISTER AND VOTE.
HOWEVER THIS LEAVES OVERSEE
CITIZENS AND MEMBERS OF THE
MILITARY DEPLOYED ABROAD OUT OF
LUCK IF THEY WISH TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF LATE BUT A
REGISTRATION AND VOTING.
PUBLISHED PROBLEM SB FIVE
BEFORE ALLOWS MILITARY OVERSEAS
CITIZENS TO ACCESS CONDITIONAL
VOTER REGISTRATION
OPPORTUNITIES. THROUGH THEIR
COUNTIES RMOTE ACCESSIBLE VOTE
BY MAIL SYSTEM. THAT'S PLACING
THEM ON EQUAL FOOTING WITH
THEIR STATESIDE COUNTERPARTS.
SB FIVE OH FOUR ALSO IMPROVES
VOTER FILE MAINTENANCE BY
HAVING AT THE DATA FOR THOSE
IMPRISONED. FOR THE CONVICTION
OF A FELONY. FLOW DIRECTLY FROM
THE DEPARTMENT F CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION.
INTERVOCALIC STATEWIDE VOTER
DATABASE. COOLEY LET'S RISE
ACROSS THE STATE RECEIVED DATA
ON JUSTICE INVOLVED PERSONS
FROM THEIR COUNTY SUPERIOR
COURT ON A PERIODIC BASIS.
HOWEVER THE DATA FROM SUPERIOR
COURT CAN BE INCOMPLETE. OR
LACKING IMPORTANT MATCHING
CRITERIA LIKE SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBERS. OR DRIVER'S LICENSE
NUMBERS. THAT WE USE TO
DIFFERENTIATE BETWEEN
INDIVIDUALS WITH. COMMON NAMES
AND THE SAME BIRTHDAY. THIS
BILL AMANDA THAT MATCH INTO-
ARE MAKE THE- GO THROUGH THE-
THIS MANDATE MATCHING. BILL
MANDATE AUTOMATING PROCESS WILL
INCREASE THE FREE. OF DATA
SUBMISSION WHICH WILL IMPROVE
VOTER REGISTRATION FILED. THANK
YOU WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE AND I'M AVAILABLE
TO HELP ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR RONCO OPERATOR. WOULD
YOU ASK IF THERE'S ANYBODY
ELSE. ACTUALLY THAT'S START
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE ANYONE ELSE HERE
TO TESTIFY IN FAVOR OF SB FIVE
OH FOUR. SEE NOW WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES ARE PRETTY WOULD
YOU ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE ON
THE LINE I WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN FAVOR OF SB FIVE OH
FOUR. AND AGAIN WE ASK AT THIS
POINT FOR THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION
OF SUPPORT AND THAT'S AS FAR AS
WHAT. WILL ALLOW SINCE WE'VE
ALREADY HAD TESTIMONY IN FAVOR.
THANK YOU. AND IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT. OF SB FIVE ZERO FOUR.
ONE NINE ZERO. SEPARATE PLAN
WILL COME FROM MY NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NINETY YEAR
LINE OF OPEN. YES THIS IS
CHRISTY SAM AND I SUPPORT SB
FIVE OH FOUR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU AND THAT'LL COME FROM LINE
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WE MET VERY ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NOW COME FROM ONE FIFTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS A NEAT SHOW
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT THE
CALIFORNIA I SUPPORT SB FIVE OH
FOUR. THANK YOU FOR CALLING IN
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU BETTER COME OVER FROM
A LINE OF FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI IS THIS IS THE SAME
NUMBERS I HAD BEFORE. THIS IS
SPS YOUR LAN. FIVE OH FOURTEEN
ALL RIGHT THIS IS THIS IS
CAROLINE FATTER WITH ELECTION
INTEGRITY CALIFORNIA I AM IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE OH FOUR
THANK YOU CAROLYN OPERATOR HOW
MANY CALLERS WE HAVE IN Q. WE
HAVE TWENTY SIX. THE OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU A
WELCOME FROM LINE OF TWENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
JENNIFER JOHNSON PLASTER COUNTY
I AM- IN FAVOR OF SB. FIVE ZERO
FOUR. THANKS OPERATE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE NEXTBOOK. A LINE
OF SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO JENNIFER MAINLY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FAD-
WHAT. THANK YOU OPERATOR YOU
CAN JUST GO OUT ONE AFTER THE
OTHER THEIR AS A TESTIMONY FOR
PLAYED HER. ALL RIGHT- LINE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
LINDA ANDERSON RIVERSIDE COUNTY
I SUPPORT AT THE FINAL FOUR.
THANK YOU CONNECT WITH A LINE
OF SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. RIGHT THE SOLANO COUNTY
SUBCOMMITTEE OUR SUPPORT OF
SPINAL CORD. THANK YOU YOU. IN
OCTOBER LINE OF EIGHTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NANCY PEARL-
ORANGE COUNTY AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE OH FOUR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NEXT ON
THE LINE OF EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. AND WORK ON THE NEXT ONE
OF LINE FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SUSAN KENNEDY SAN DIEGO COUNTY
IN SUPPORT AT FIVE OH FOUR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU EXCELL GOAL
LINE OF FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BIGGER ORANGE COUNTY
SUPPORT SB FIVE OH FOUR THANKS
FOR. NEXT OVER LINE OF SIXTY
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES
THIS IS PATRICIA MICHELE-
IRVINE IN ORANGE COUNTY AND I
SUPPORT SB. FIVE OH FOUR. THANK
YOU THANK YOU IN MEXICO LINE OF.
FIFTY SIX. NANCY MADSEN REVERSE
INDIVIDUAL IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
I SUPPORT SB FIVE OLD FOR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
OVERFLIGHT OF SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NANCY WRITER
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AN EXTRA LINE OF SIXTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JANICE
DUPORT PLASTER COUNTY I SUPPORT
BY THE FOR. THANK YOU AN EXTRA
LINE OF SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I AM BRADFORD ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT I'M IN
SUPPORT OF FIVE OH FOUR. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF SIXTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. CLOSE THE CHURRO FROM
PLASTER COUNTY AND WITH THE
ELECTION TECH READY PROJECT I'M
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE OH FOUR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT OVER A
LINE OF NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI ANGELA ST SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY AND I SUPPORT BIBLE FOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
ALTHOUGH LINE OF FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS. AND FOR MICHAEL SACRAMENTO
COUNTY HI FOR. ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT A LITTLE LINE OF
A THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MY NAME IS KIM ANDERSON- IN
PLASTER COUNTY AND ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT MY SUPPORT AT
THE BATTLE FOR. THANK YOU
NEXAVAR LINE OF SEVENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. JOHN LOPEZ
INTERCOUNTY. SELECT INTEGRITY
PROJECT I SUPPORT SB FIVE ZERO
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS ALKA MITCHELL SAN
DIEGO COUNTY. A REGISTERED
VOTER I SUPPORT FIVE OH FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT
TO A LINE OF TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME IS
SHARON WASHINGTON THE PERSON OF
COLOR AND I SUPPORT AT THE
FINAL FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THE LINE OF TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES MY NAME
IS LYNETTE IS NASTY AND EAGLE
COUNTY RESIDENT ON THE LEGAL
STATUS AND VOTING LEGAL HE
FOLLOWED VIçT AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB FIVE OH FOUR THANK
YOU THANKS CALLER PLEASE
OPERATOR HOW MANY MORE COLORS
IN Q. WE HAVE EIGHT THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THAT'LL
COME FROM ONE OF FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DIANNE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY RESIDENT I THINK
WORK OUT THE BIBLE FOR. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE THANK
YOU FOR. WHAT A LINE OF THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES **** ROBIN TURNER CAIRNEY
STRONGLY SUPPORT SENATE BILL
FIVE OH COOL. THANK YOU NEXT
THANK YOU. WHAT A LINE OF
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE WELCOME THAT
COLOR OF LINE THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. KATHERINE MOURNER
WITH SANTA CLARA COUNTY
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT OF
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT SB
FIVE OH FOUR THANK YOU THE
CALLER PLEASE. THEY'LL COME
FROM MINE OF FIFTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MARY ELLEN REALLY
BIGELOW SAN MATEO COUNTY. I'M
IN SUPPORT OF FIVE OH FOUR WITH
THE FIFTY EIGHT CONCERT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THAT'LL COME
FROM LIKE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY AND THEN
WE'LL GO NON THE NEXT NINE OF
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
RECORDIST ALAMEDA COUNTY I'M IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE WILL GO INTO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATOR
WOULD YOU GIVE A FINAL LAST
CALL FOR ANYONE WISH TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION
SB FIVE OH FOUR SO WE CAN GET
THEM IN Q. YES. IF YOU LIKE-
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT ONE ZERO.
AND OUR NEXT LINE WILL COME
FROM. NINE EIGHTY SEVEN. MY
NAME. THIS IS MARLENA DE FREIN
I AM IN I'M FROM SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY AND I'M IN SUPPORT AND-
SB FIVE OH FOUR THANK YOU FOR
CALLING IN NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BETTER COME FROM LINE TWENTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS
CAROL WILSON PLASTER COUNTY
CENTRAL COMMITTEE IN SUPPORT SB
FIVE BALTIMORE THANK YOU FOR
CALLING AND NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BETTER COME FROM LINE OF THIRTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SACRAMENTO LOS ANGELES COUNTY
THE FOURTH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BETTER COME
FROM LINE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MEL BLANC
AND I'M SUPPORT AT SB FIVE OH
FOUR THANK YOU GIONALE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THAT'LL COME
FROM NINE OF EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN- MY NAME IS
PHYLLIS CARVALLO SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE OH FOUR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. AN
ELECTRONIC YOU COME FROM LINE
THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ROBIN
PAGE THEN WE THE PEOPLE RISING
STRONG SUPPORT SB FIVE OH FOUR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OPERATORS
ACT INCLUDING ONE ON THE LINE
THERE. THAT DOES CONCLUDE IT
VERY GOOD OKAY APART THANK YOU
SO MUCH OPERATOR FOR YOUR
WONDERFUL ASSISTANCE THAT TODAY
WOULD PRECIADO VERY MUCH. LET'S
GO TO THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE AFFORDS OR ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SB FIVE OH FOUR. I SEE
NEVER GONNA GO TO THE PHONE
LINES ARE PRETTY WOULD YOU ASK
IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE OH FOUR PLEASE. YES HERE
IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE ZERO
PROPOSITIONS. AND IF YOU'RE
CARE WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION IN
P. ALL RIGHT OFFERED LET'S GIVE
IT ONE LAST FINAL CALL FOR
ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION CAN YOU ASK ONE MORE
TIME. YES IN OPPOSITION. OF SB
FIVE ALL FOR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE NO ONE
IN Q. THANK YOU SO MUCH
OPERATOR LET'S BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
DISCUSSION QUESTIONS. MEMBERS
SAID SENATOR NIELSEN CENTER
NEWMAN. FEDERICO SEN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN THIS IS NOT SUFFICIENT
FOR ME TO BE DISPOSED OF OR- IN
OPPOSITION BUT IT IS IMPORTANT
TO NOTE. THERE'S A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN PAROLED AND DISCHARGED
FROM PAROLE. THE SENTENCE IS
NOT EXTINGUISHED IN MOST CASES
UNTIL ONE IS DISCHARGED
FORMALLY DISCHARGE I WOULD
SUGGEST THE AUTHOR CONSIDERS IT
MOVES ALONG ADDING THE WORD
DISCHARGED FROM PAROLE THAT
MEANS THEIR DEBT TO SOCIETY HAS
BEEN COMPLETELY EXTINGUISHED
BUT PAROLE DOESN'T NECESSARILY
MEAN THAT. THANK YOU CENTER
NIELSEN SENATOR NEWMAN. AND
THINK WITH YOUR HEAD I DON'T
SOMETHING IS DONE RIGHT I DO
HAVE A QUESTION CURIOUS SO THIS
BILL INCLUDES BOTH PROVISIONS
FOR- MILITARY VOTERS BUT ALSO-
BUT PROVISIONS ON- PAROLEES
DISCHARGE CERTAIN SEEMINGLY ODD
PAIRING HOW IS IT THAT BOTH OF
THESE ELEMENTS ON THE SAME BILL
SURE SURE THE REASON I CAME TO
US BECAUSE- THEY WERE- THEY
BOTH INVOLVE CHANGES TO THE
VOTER REGISTRATION PROCESS AND
REGIONAL WAS. CONCEIVED OR BOTH
CONDITION AROUND THE
CONDITIONAL VOTER ON THAT PIECE
AND- AS WE PROCEEDED ALONG-
THEY WERE BOTH STILL INVOLVE
CHANGES TO THE VOTER
REGISTRATION PROCESS NOT
EXACTLY BOTH CONDITIONAL VOTER
PIECE BUT WE DECIDED TO KEEP
THEM TOGETHER. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU AGAIN IT APPEARS THAT YOU
HAVE IN SUPPORT MANY THE SAME
FOLKS WHO OPPOSE LAST BILL SO I
COMMEND. YOU ON YOUR BI
PARTISANSHIP. THANK YOU FOR. HI
DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER. THIS
HURTS. SENATOR NEWMAN IF THAT'S
THE CASE SHOULD WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL IT'S YOU'LL LINCOLN'S
STORY YOU KNOW THE WHOLE STORY.
IT WAS SHOULD WE OPPOSE THIS
BILL HAS THAT YOU GET THE SAME
PEOPLE ON THE FLIP SIDE OF THE
DEAL I DON'T THINK IT'S SOME TO
BE COMMENDED FOR I THINK IT'S
WHICH PROBABLY OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE. DON'T YOU THINK SO.
AND SENATOR OUT LEYVA THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR QUICK QUESTION OF
THE AUTHOR DID I READ THAT THE-
CDCR HOUSE REPORT EACH WEEK
ABOUT THE GIVE US AN UPDATE IS
THAT CORRECT I JUST WANT TO
SAID IF THAT'S TRUE I THINK
THAT'S GREAT BECAUSE I THINK
SOMETIMES WE WAIT TOO LONG
BEFORE WE CHECK BACK IN AND
FOLKS DON'T- DON'T NECESSARILY
ACCESS THE RIGHTS YES THIS IS A
SINGLE WEEKLY FLOW OF
INFORMATION THAT'S GREAT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- CENTER- DECKER I
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL TO US I DON'T HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS. AND WE
WELCOME YOUR CLOSING REMARKS I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS SO LOOK
AT THE COMMENT FROM- MY
COLLEAGUES- AND- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TERRIFIC
THANK YOU- CENTER LAY THIS MOVE
THE BILL AND WITH THAT IF THE
CONSULTANT CALL THE ROLL. THIS
IS DUE PASS. AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
IS THAT CORRECT. YEAH OKAY. SB
FIVE OH FOUR THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
GLAZER HI WE EITHER BY NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE HERTZBERG. HI LEYVA
AYE LEYVA AYE NEWMAN ALL RIGHT
NEWMAN HI. ALL RIGHT THAT BILLS
OUT FIVE ZERO IT'S A IT'S A
GREAT DAY FOR YOU SENATOR BACK
FOR GRADUATIONS ON YOUR SECOND
FIRST BILL GETTING OUT THANK
YOU ALL. AND NEXT TIME WE GET A
PODIUM FOR YOU I THINK THAT WAS
THAT PART OF THE HAZING THAT
HAPPENS. I HEAR OKAY. I HAVE
MEMBERS ARE GONNA- WHY DO WE
TAKE AT YEAH WE'RE TO MOVE ON
TO THE SENATOR DIED AND THAT
FOR THOSE WHO CAME OUT LATER WE
GOT THE CONSENT CALENDARS ON
CALL HE'LL HAVE A CHANCE TO
VOTE ON THAT. SENATOR JOHN WE
WELCOME YOU THIS IS SB ONE OF
THREE UNIFORMED FAITHFUL
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTORS ACT. I
WONDER IF YOU REALLY NAMED IT
THAT BUT WE'LL LOOK FORTY
TESTIMONY. TODAY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I WATER THERE
IS NO PODIUM AND YOU'RE NOT ON
TV THIS MORNING SO. THERE'S NO
RESPECT FOR YOUR COMMITTEE
EXCEPT FOR FROM. THIS BILL THE
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL HAS. THE
UTMOST RESPECT FOR THE COUNTRY.
I'M ABOUT TO- PRESENT TO. SO
WITH THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS. ARE FIRST OF ALL I
WILL I WILL BE TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS SUGGESTED THE
ANALYSIS INTAKE THE COMMITTEE
STAFF- THEY'RE VERY VERY GOOD
WORK ON THIS BILL. I WITH THE
AMERICAN VOTERS CAST YOUR
BALLOT FOR PRESIDENT THE UNITED
STATES. THEY WERE ELECTING A
SLATE OF ELECTORS. THESE
ELECTORS THEN CAST BALLOTS. TO
DECIDE WHO WILL BE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES. IF THESE
BALLOTS ARE CAST IN A WAY THAT
REFLECTS THE WILL OF THE
VOTERS. THERE ARE DOT.
DEMOCRACY CEASES TO FUNCTION.
THE SO CALLED PEOPLE SELECT-
HOLDS THE POTENTIAL FOR GREAT
POLITICAL CHAOS. SB ONE OH
THREE PROVIDES FOR A STATE
ADMINISTERED. PLEDGE OF
FAITHFULNESS FROM ELECTORS. ANY
ATTEMPT BY ELECTRIC TO SUBMIT A
VOTE IN VIOLATION OF THAT
PLEDGE WELL THEN EFFECTIVELY
CONSTITUTE RESIGNATION FROM THE
OFFICE OF ELECTOR WITH THIS
BILL CALIFORNIA WILL JOIN
THIRTY OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
TAKEN THE ACTION TO DISCOURAGE
OR FORBID FAITHLESS ELECTORAL
VOTES. HERE TESTIFIED SUPPORT
IS COMMISSIONER MARTY CAR
LEGISLATIVE LIAISON FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
UNIFORM STATE LAWS. THANK YOU
CENTER DIED AND WE WELCOME THE
MISTER CAR. TO OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING OPERATOR IF YOU WOULD
OPEN UP THE LINE FOR MARTY
CARLOS WE GET HERE STASHED
MONEY. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
GLAZER GOOD MORNING SENATORS
CAN HEAR ME WE CAN'T HEAR YOU
THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR GIVING
ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY ABOUT SENATOR
DODD SB ONE OF THREE
CALIFORNIA'S VERSION OF THE
UNIFORM FAITHFUL PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTORS ACT I'VE BEEN A MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
UNIFORM STATE LAWS FOR OVER A
DECADE IN THAT TIME I'VE SERVED
AS CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR OF THE
C. C. U. S. L. AND I'M
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA'S
LEGISLATIVE LIAISON TO THE
NATIONAL UNIFORM LAW
COMMSSION. I WILL NOTE THAT
THE CUMBERSOME NAME OF THIS ACT
IS THE U. L. C.'S FAULT IT IS
NOT SENATOR GODSWILL. FOR
ALMOST A HUNDRED THIRTY YEARS
THE YOU'LL SEE HAS PROVIDED
STATES WITH NONPARTISAN WELL
CONCEIVED AND WELL DRAFTED
LEGISLATION. THAT BRINGS
CLARITY AND STABILITY TO
CRITICAL AREAS OF STATE
STATUTORY LAW. SOME EXAMPLES
ENACTED IN CALIFORNIA- THE
UNIFORM COMMERCIAL CODE UNIFORM
VOIDABLE TRANSACTIONS ACT. AND
SENATOR DODD'S UNIFORM
RECOGNITION AND ENFORCEMENT OF
CANADIAN DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PROTECTION ORDERS ACT. FROM TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN. SB ONE OH
THREE UNIFORMED PEOPLE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTORS ACT
ADDRESSED THE POTENTIAL PROBLEM
THAT HAS LONG BEEN RECOGNIZED
IN CALIFORNIA LAW. IT PROVIDES
A FAR BETTER SOLUTION THAN OUR
EXISTING STATUTE. FOR MANY
YEARS CALIFORNIA LAW IS HELD
THAT A PRESIDENTIAL ELECTOR
VOTES CONTRARY TO HIS OR HR
COMMITMENT CAN BE FINED OR EVEN
IMPRISONED. THIS IS ALL WELL
AND GOOD BUT OUR EXISTING LAW
DOES NOTHING TO INVALIDATE THE
FACELESS VOTE. SO I UNDER
EXISTING LAW THE VOTE THAT THE
FAITHLESS ELECTORS WILL STAND
IN THE WILL OF THE VOTERS WE
FRUSTRATED. THE INFORMATICA
EMBODIED IN SB ONE OF THREE
CREATES A MECHANISM THAT
PRETENSE OF FACELESS VOTE FROM
COUNTING REPLACES THE FAITHLESS
ELECTOR. THIS THIS IS SIMPLE
COMMON SENSE AND IN TWENTY
TWENTY. THE SUPREME COURT CASE
OF COLORADO B. BALK AT UNITED
STATES SUPREME COURT FOUND THAT
SUCH A MECHANISM IS
CONSTITUTIONAL. SIX STATES HAVE
ALREADY ADOPTED THE UNIFORM ACT
AND FOURTEEN OTHERS HAD THEIR
OWN VERY SIMILAR RULES. FEW
THINGS ARE MORE IMPORTANT THAN
A VOTE OF THE PEOPLE IN A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION SO I URGE
YOU TO PASS THE STREET PORT
IMPROVEMENTS FOR EXISTING
CALIFORNIA LAW TO THIS
COMMITTEE. ANYONE HAS A
QUESTION I'LL BE HAPPY TO DO MY
BEST TO ANSWER IT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CAR. AYE WE'VE HEARD
FROM OUR LEAD WITH US IN
SUPPORT OF THE SB ONE OH THREE
LET'S GO TO THE HEARING ROOM
HERE TODAY IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN FAVOR.
SEE NOW WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES OPERATOR. WOULD YOU ASK
IF ANYBODY WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE OH
THREE TO PLEASE SO INDICATE AND
LET ME MENTION THAT SINCE
WE'VE- TAKEN TESTIMONY. WE JUST
ASK INDIVIDUALS TO GIVE THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND THEIR
POSITION. ON THE BILL OPERATOR
PLEASE- PLEASE PROCEED. WELL
THANK YOU IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT. OF A THREE ONE ZERO
THREE MY PRESS ONE ZERO NOW.
ONE ZERO IN SUPPORT. AND
THAT'LL COME FROM LINE NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY. AND I AM SUPPORTING
THIS THANK YOU VERY MUCH HELP
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
AND AS A REMINDER OF YOUR IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRES ONE ZERO
NOW. AND OUR NEXT ONE WILL COME
FROM LINE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WHAT PER MONTH FULL
MOON SACRAMENTO COUNTY. RIGHT-
WITH THE- YEAH. THANK YOU.
SUPPORT MY PRESS ONE AND THEN.
ZERO IF YOU WERE IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. ONE ZERO THREE MY PRESS
ONE ZERO NOW. AND THAT'LL COME
FROM NEXT FINE WILL COME FROM
LINE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NANCY MADSEN INDIVIDUAL-
PER SE COUNTY I SUPPORT SB ONE
OH THREE THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU AMERICAN FROM
LINE OF THIRTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. REMEMBER SYMPTOMS AFTER
COUNTY AND I SUPPORT THAT'S THE
ONE THREE. THANK YOU NEXT CALL
PLEASE. YES I'M A REMINDER IF
YOU WERE IN SUPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ONE ZERO
IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE ZERO THREE
WILL MAKE THAT OUR FINAL CALL
PRESS ONE THE FINAL CALL FOR
THOSE WHO LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS P. ONE OF THREE
OPERATOR ANYBODY ELSE IN Q.
THERE'S NOBODY ELSE IN KILL
TERRIFIC THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO OPPONENTS
OF SB ONE OH THREE. THREE LADY
HERE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL HERE AND THEY ARE
HEARING ROOM. SEE NOW WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR
WOULD YOU ASK IF THERE'S ANYONE
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TO SB ONE OR THREE
TO PLEASE SO INDICATE. YES IF
YOU'RE NOT THE VISION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO NOW. IF YOU WERE
IN OPPOSITION OF SB. ONE ZERO
THREE. AND OUR FIRST LINE WILL
COME FROM ONE FIFTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MARY ELLEN ELLIE
BIGELOW MATTEO COUNTY AYE
OPPOSED SB ONE OF THREE. THANK
YOU FOR CALLING AN OPERATOR
NEXT. AND THAT'LL COME FROM MY
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BY TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN YES. MY NAME IS LYNN
METZNER ON THE LEGAL VOTING LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS IN OPPOSE THE
SB. THIRTY FIVE. WE'RE NOT THAT
I THANK YOU FOR CALLING IN AND
WE'LL OF RECORD THAT FOR THE-
FOR THE FUTURE MEASURE THIS IS
SB ONE OF THREE BY SENATOR DIED.
OPERATOR ANYBODY ELSE IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. ONE OH
THREE BY SENATOR JOHN. YEAH IF
YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION OF SB
ONE ALL THREE OF MY PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND THE NEXT ONE WILL
COME FROM MY TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES MANAGER IN
WASHINGTON ON THE PERSON OF
COLOR. I'M IN OPPOSITION OF THE
LEGISLATION. AT THE REMINDER.
IN OPPOSITION OF SB ONE ALL
GREAT YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
NOW. AND WE HAVE NO MORE
OPPOSITION INK YOU ARE AT LEAST
TWO OF ONE THE LAST AND FINAL
CALL ON THAT OPERATOR LAST
CHANCE FOR ANYONE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION S. B. ONE OH THREE.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AND THERE IS NO ONE
INTERESTED OPERATOR THANK YOU
AGAIN LET'S BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ANY
MEMBERS HAVE COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS. I WOULD DO- AND WE
ASK QUESTIONS CENTER JOB BEFORE
WE GIVE ME A CHANCE TO CLOSE
SENATOR DIED- THIS IMPORTANT
BILL YOU. ABSOLUTELY AND YOU'VE
BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE HOW
LONG HOW MANY PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTIONS HAVE GONE BY. SINCE
I'VE BEEN IN THE LEGISLATURE
YES TO AND WHY DID IT TAKE YOU
SO LONG TO BRING THIS BILL TO
US. THAT'S A SUCH IMPORTANCE.
WELL IS ESSENTIAL I DON'T THINK
IN MY LIFETIME WE'VE EVER SEEN
A SITUATION. WHERE IS THIS IS
REALLY COME TO THE FOREFRONT-
WHAT COULD ACTUALLY HAPPEN WITH
THE WILL OF THE VOTERS. ISN'T
IS NOT IT HERE TOO THANK YOU
THAT'S VERY PERSUASIVE TO ME
AND I'M GONNA SUPPORT THIS BILL
TODAY. OFFERED YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY CLOTHES SUCH AN
IMPORTANT BILL. WELL MISTER
CHAIRMAN SINCE I WAS TREATED
LIKE THIS IS MY FIRST BILL- IT
YOU KNOW EVER IN THE HISTORY OF
THE LEGISLATURE BY. THE
ESTEEMED CHAIRMAN AND- I'M A
LITTLE BIT PERPLEXED BUT- I DO
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE. HEARD ADD TO HAVE THIS BILL
HEARD TODAY RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVALS. THANK YOU SENATOR
DODD THANK YOU FOR YOUR GOOD
SENSE OF HUMOR AS WELL IT'S
HARD TO SEE IT SOMETIMES BEHIND
HIS MASK ZERO ELSE. YEAH I
THINK WE'RE GOOD WE HAVE A
CLOSE- I THINK DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. WELL WE DO HAVE A
MOTION CENTER LEYVA TO- DO
PASSES AMENDED I THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THAT THE AMENDMENTS. A
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS- BUT FIRST
BE RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS OF THE CONSOLE A
CALL THE ROLL. SB ONE OH THREE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST BE REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. GLAZER HI. WE
THIRD HI. NIELSEN NIELSEN HI
HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT HERTZBERG
HI LEYVA I LEYVA AYE NEWMAN ALL
RIGHT YOU MAY I. GRADUAL CENTER
DOT HAS FIVE ZERO THAT BILLS.
AND YOUR HUMOR YOU'LL HEAR HOME
OR IS IT TOO INTO SO IF YOU
TOTALLY REYES WHO THREE DAY
TODAY. ALL RIGHT- DO WE HAVE
CENTER I BURKE HERE. I WOULD
LIKE TO INVITE CENTER TO THE
ROOM BY WE'RE WAITING CENTER
I'M BUT WE DO ONE BILL CALL-
THEY CAN CALENDAR THAT TEST
THREE OH FIVE BY JOHN TO THE
CONSULTANT PAUL THE ROLE AGAIN.
ON THE CALENDAR THE CURRENT
VOTE IS FOUR ZERO WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING ONLINE THE VICE
CHAIR VOTING AYE HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG BY GREAT THAT BILL IS
OUT FIVE ZERO ALL RIGHT WE'RE
AT- THE FIFTH ITEM ON OUR
AGENDA. SB THIRTY FIVE I
CENTER- BURKE. AND WE INVITE
THE CENTER TO COME TO THE THAT
THE FOR THE NON PODIUM. TO HASH.
THIS YEAR IS- WITH ABOUT THIS
THIS IMPORTANT.
OKAY. THANK YOU
YEAH. OKAY OKAY BOB. YEAH RIGHT
RIGHT. YEAH.
YEAH- BUT ANYBODY
THAT ISN'T VERY HARD WE HAVE AN
YOUR. YEAH YEAH YEAH. YEAH ALEX-
HER NUMBER PROUD OF- YEAH YEAH.
PLEASE HOLD ON OF YEAH IF THE.
RIGHT NOW THINK THE OTHER THIS
YEAR WE'RE- FIND THE CENTER
OVER IT'S GREAT TO WELCOME YOU
YEAH WE DO PROCEED TO FAST
PERHAPS IN THE HIS NOR HERE IN
THE. WILL LEAVE THE TO THE ARE.
TO CREATE CHAIR WAS VERY. OKAY
CENTER OVER THIS IS ITEM- FOR
IN OUR AGENDA THIRTY FIVE AND
WE WILL BE YOU TO THE CAN LOOK
YOUR TEST. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LET ME BEGIN THINK YOU'RE
VERY TELL TO STAFF PARTICULAR
MISTER MATSUMOTO BEFORE HE EX
WORK- I WANT ACCEPT THESE CHEN
REMEMBER TO THE BILL- CLEAR
THAT THE BUFFER INTO. AND LAW
SHOULD BE TO ENCOMPASS.
LISTENING ABOUT SPEAKING TO A
VOTER REGARDING THE BALLOT OR
PASSING OUT LECTIONARY
INFORMATION- ADDITIONALLY WILL
CLARIFY THE MEANING OF THE
UNOFFICIAL BALLOT BOX. TO
INCLUDE. UNAUTHORIZED BELT
BOXES A THE OFFICE. AS OF YOU
KNOW THERE WAS AN ISSUE IN THIS
PAST ELECTION WITH. A BALLOT
BOXES. BEING DESIGNATED AS
OFFICIAL. AND THEY JUST SEEM TO
BE FILING CABINETS UP POSITION
OUTSIDE OF DEIR AZ VENUES- WE
ALSO ACCEPT THE MEMBERS
CONCERNING TECHNICAL HANGES.
THE BILL BEFORE YOU SB THIRTY
FIVE WILL PRESERVE ORDER AND
ACCESS THE BALLOT BOX BY
EXPANDING THE AREA INSIDE WHICH
ELECTION HEARING ACTIVITIES MAY
NOT TAKE PLACE IN BY CLARIFYING
THE VOTERS WHO CAST VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOTS DROP BOXES HAVE
THE SAME PROTECTIONS AS THOSE
WHO VOTED SATELLITE LOCATIONS.
UP WE EXPAND THE- AREA ALEXION
ACTIVITIES AND VOTER
INTIMIDATION EFFORTS MAY NOT
TAKE PLACE TO TWO HUNDRED FEET
FROM THE ENTRANCE TO A PLACE
WHERE VOTING IS A CURRENT SO
FOR EXAMPLE. IF THE ACTUAL-
CASTING OF BALLOTS IS INSIDE OF
THE BUILDING BUT MAY BE A
DISTANCE AWAY FROM THE DOOR
THAT THE DISTANCE MEASURED IS
FROM THE DOOR NOT FROM THE
ACTUAL FOR EXAMPLE PULLING BOTH.
THESE THESE ISSUES GROW OUT OF
VOTER INTIMIDATION HARASSMENT
SO FOR EXAMPLE- IN NEVADA
NEVADA CITY NEVADA COUNTY END
OF IT THE MEMBER POLICE
RECEIVED COMPLAINTS ABOUT
ELECTION DURING ACTIVITIES
BLOCKING ACCESS TO A VOTING
CENTER IN TEMECULA PARK NO THE
PARTS OF THE STATE AS YOU KNOW
UNOFFICIAL. BALLOT BOXES DOES
HIS OFFICIAL WORK WERE PLACED.
I WOULD ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE WE
ALSO HAVE WITH US TODAY
TESTIFYING. BOB REMOTELY MISS
NATALIE- DONNA I DON'T KNOW
NEVADA COUNTY ASSISTANT CLERK
RECORDER REGISTRAR OF VOTERS
AND MISS ESPERANZA S. B.
MARTINEZ- BOAT CENTER SUPPORT
LEAD ORANGE COUNTY REGISTER
VOTERS. THANK YOU SENATOR ON
BURKE AT. WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
YOUR LEAD WITNESSES- MS- I
DON'T A AND M'S MARTINEZ WE UP
INVITE THEIR INVITE THEIR
TESTIMONY INDICATE ASK THEM TO
TRY TO LIMIT IT TO TWO MINUTES
EACH AN OPERATOR WOULD YOU
INVITE TO THIS NATALIE A DONUT
TO BEGIN HER TESTIMONY. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
EVERYONE CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN
HEAR YOU FINE. GREAT THANK YOU
SENATOR- BURKE AND
DISTINGUISHED COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR INVITING ME TO SPEAK THIS
MORNING MY NAME IS NATALIE A
DONNA AND I REPRESENT NEVADA
COUNTY ELECTIONS WHICH SUPPORT
SB THIRTY FIVE. NEVADA COUNTY
IS ONE OF FIFTEEN COUNTY THAT
ADMINISTERS ELECTIONS UNDER THE
VOTERS CHOICE ACT UNDER THE BCA
WE OFFER SEVERAL OPTIONS FOR
RETURNING A VOTED BALLOT
INCLUDING AN OFFICIAL DROPBOX.
IN ABOUT A COUNTY APPROXIMATELY
50% OF RETURN BALLOTS FROM THE
NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION
WILL RETURN TO BE A DROP BOX.
SB THIRTY FIVE PROVIDES MUCH
NEEDED CLARITY AND AFORDS DROP
BOXES ROBUST PROTECTIONS
AGAINST ELECTIONEERING IT ALSO
MAKES CLEAR THAT ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS ESTABLISHED IN
CLARKSON'S AND NO ONE ELSE.
DURING THE VOTING PERIOD LAST
YEAR I WITNESSED A SATURDAY
POLITICAL RALLY OF AROUND THREE
HUNDRED TRUMP SUPPORTERS
GATHERED IN THE COUNTY PARKING
LOT. PARTICIPANTS BLOCK ACCESS
TO THE DROP BOX IN OUR PARKING
LOT WHICH HAS ENTRANCES OUTSIDE
OF THE CURRENT ONE HUNDRED FOOT
ELECTIONEERING BUFFER ZONES.
ALL PARTICIPANTS HAVE SOME FORM
OF PROHIBITED ELECTION HEARING
SUCH AS LARGE FLAG WITH THE
CANDIDATE'S NAME AND LIKENESS
DECORATING NEARLY EVERY CAR. I
HADN'T TEACHER TENDER AND
AMPLIFIED POLITICAL SPEECH THAT
I COULD HEAR FROM THE SECOND
FLOOR OF MY OFFICE. UPSET
VOTERS CALLED US SAYING THAT
THEY COULDN'T ACCESS THE DROP
BOX OR SELF INTIMIDATED
APPROACHING THE DROP BOX WHILE
THE RALLY WAS TAKING PLACE. ALL
BOATERS OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO
DROP OFF THEIR VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOT IN A CALM NONPARTISAN
ENVIRONMENT. VOTER SHOULD NEVER
FEEL INTIMIDATED WHEN CATCHING
THE BALLOT A BALLOT AND SHOULD
NOT BE FORCED TO FIND ANOTHER
LOCATION TO VOTE. SB THIRTY
FIVE WILL HELP BY EXTENDING THE
NO ELECTION HEARING DOCTORS
DON'T FROM ONE HUNDRED TO TWO
HUNDRED FEET. PROVIDING
STRONGER VOTER ACCESS AND
PROTECTION TO ALL OF OUR TOP
OPTION. SB THIRTY FIVE HELPS
PROTECT MY OFFICE PROTECT ALL
OF OUR VOTERS FROM
INTIMIDATION. I ENCOURAGE YOU
ALL TO CONSIDER VOTING IN FAVOR
OF SB THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER DONUT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE THERE IN
NEVADA COUNTY- OPERATOR WE
WOULD INVITE ESPERANZA MARTINEZ
TO PROVIDE HER TESTIMONY NOW.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU CHAIRED
GLAZER AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SB MARTINEZ I AM A BIT BETTER
SUPPORT LEAD FOR ORANGE COUNTY
REGISTER VOTERS. GETTING
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF THAT
AND ORANGE COUNTY. EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION THIS BILL WILL
BRING MUCH NEEDED CLARITY AND
PROTECTIONS TO VOTERS AND
ELECTION WORKERS FOLLOWING THE
TWENTY TWENTY AFFECTION THE
ORANGE COUNTY EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION CONVENED A MEETING
WITH SENATOR UMBERG WHERE WE
REVIEWED HOW THE ELECTION WENT
AND FLAGGED POTENTIAL ISSUES WE
SAW ON THE FIELD. WE DISCUSS
WITH THEM SENATOR- BURKE SOME
CONFUSION THAT OCCURRED AT THE
HONDA CENTER WHICH SERVED AS A
VOTE TENER SUPERSITE IN ORANGE
COUNTY. THE ISSUE OF AFFECTION
BACKER NEEDED CLARITY THERE IS
A LOCAL CANDIDATE THAT WAS
UNCLEAR ABOUT ELECTION NEARING
AND INTERPRETED THE LAW AS
MEANING OVER ONE HUNDRED FEET
FROM THE ENTIRE VENUE NOT FROM
THE ENTRANCE TO THE BUILDING
ROOM. AND ADDITION TO ROUTE
ORANGE COUNTY BEING COUNTERED
ISSUES AROUND UNAUTHORIZED
BALLOT DROP BOXES POSING AS
OFFICIAL AND EVEN A CAMPAIGN
OFFICE THAT CLAIM TO BE AN
OFFICIAL POLLING PLACE. I FROM
BOTH GENDERS WE ALSO WITNESSED
ISSUES WITH LONG LINES IT IS
SOCIAL DISTANCING PROTOCOLS
WHERE VOTERS WERE SUBJECT TO
ELECTION HEARING JUST BECAUSE
THEY WERE IN LINES THAT
EXTENDED BEYOND THE HUNDRED
FOOT BUFFER. I BELIEVE THAT
CLARITY AND LONG AND ADDED
PROTECTION WILL MAKE THE VOTING
EXPERIENCE BETTER FOR BOTH
VOTERS ELECTION WORKERS AND
POLL WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU FOR HEARING MY
TESTIMONY TODAY I APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH
YOU ARE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
MS MARTINEZ FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
RIGHT THAT COMPLETES THE
TESTIMONY OF OUR LEAD-
WITNESSES IN FAVOR WE'RE GONNA
NOW ASKED FOR OF THOSE WHO
WOULD LIKE TO PUT THEIR NAME ON
THE RECORD IN SUPPORT TO ALSO
SO INDICATE WILL FIRST START
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. THREE
ONE HERE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN.
FAVOR OF- SB THIRTY FIVE. C.
NOT GOING TO GO TO THE PHONE
LINE OPERATE WOULD YOU ASK IF
THERE'S A FOLKS WHO WOULD LIKE
TO PUT THEIR NAY ON THE- IT'S A-
TO POLICE INDICATE. ASK THIRTY
FIVE AND- THANK YOU.IF YOU
WERE IN SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY FIVE ONE AND THEN ZERO.
FIRST NUMBER COME FROM LINE UP
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
MISTER CHAIR COUNTY TO DERO WE
HAVE TO CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OPERATOR NEXT. THANK
YOU. AND IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
OF SB THIRTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. NEXT LEVEL
COME FROM NINETY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MISTER CHAIRMAN
THIS CATAMARN WITH ERIN
READING THE SOCIUS REPRESENTING
THE ORANGE COUNTY EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANKS CALLER
PLEASE. YES AND JUST AS A
REMINDER IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY FIVE IT IS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT. YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND ERIC ON THE- DURING THE Q.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES THIS IS
ERIC HARRIS FROM DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA CALLING IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER HARRIS. AT THE TO FOR
TODAY GIVE YOU IN FRONT OF OUR
COMMITTEE WELL DONE. OPERATOR
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT SB
THIRTY FIVE WE HAVE A CALL. NO
FURTHER. SUPPORT IN Q. TRAFFIC
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH LET'S
GO TO OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTY
FIVE IS THERE ANYONE HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM. IN OPPOSITION
TO CENTER ON DRUGS SB THIRTY
FIVE. THE NUMBER GO TO THE
PHONE LINES OPERATOR WOULD YOU
ASK I THERE'S ANYONE A WE DO
HAVE A LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS.
I BELIEVE IS ON THE PHONE LINE
RUTH WEISS TO SEE IF AYE SHE'S
ON THE PHONE LINE- SO PLEASE
WELCOME HER. TO OUR COMMITTEE.
YES THANK YOU SO MUCH- I WANT
TO MAKE THE POINT ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT CALIFORNIA
HAS NO OBJECTION. TO EXTENDING
THE NO ELECTION HEARING DOWN
FROM ONE HUNDRED TO TWO HUNDRED
FEET WE FULLY SUPPORT. THIS
ELEMENT OF THE BILL. BUT
SECTION ONE EIGHT FIVE SIX DATE
OF SB THIRTY FIVE IS THE ONE
THAT CONCERNS US. YEAH PCA HAS
BEEN. IN CONCERT. HELD AT THE-
THAT THIRD. BALLOT BY
INDIVIDUAL. WHO ARE NOT CLOSE
RELATIVES ARE MEMBERS OF THE
HOUSEHOLD OR TRUSTED ASSOCIATES
THE VOTER. MUST BE. BY ANY
SYSTEM THAT VALUES INTEGRITY.
GIVEN THE PREVALENCE AND
CONVENIENCE OF PRIVATE AND
PUBLIC MAILBOXES. AS WELL AS
COMMUNITY DROP BOXES THERE IS
NO CALIFORNIA VOTER. WONDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCE TO BE. OR
INCONVENIENCE BY BEING EXPECTED
TO POST A BALLOT ON AIDED. BY
THIRD. OUTSIDE THE CATEGORIES
LISTED ABOVE. I'M BALLOTS. AS
CONDONED EIGHTY NINETEEN TWENTY
ONE THAT WAS PASSED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN. OPENS THE DOOR TO
VOTER HARASSMENT AND
INTIMIDATION AS WELL AS VOTE
BUYING AND SELLING. AND MANY
OTHER FORMS OF ELECTION
CORRUPTION. VOTERS AND
OBSERVERS HAVE PROVIDED
DOCUMENTATION E. IPCA SIGNED
UNDER PENALTY OF PERJURY. THAT
ALL OF THE ABOVE SITUATIONS
WERE MANIFESTED AS A RESULT OF
AB NINETEEN TWENTY ONE. AND IN
LOS ANGELES PROSECUTIONS
RESULTED FROM THE PAYING OF
INDIVIDUALS FOR THEIR
SIGNATURES. CHAIN OF CUSTODY.
BACK AND ASSIST THEM WITH
INTEGRITY. THE MOLLUSC BREACH
OF CHAIN OF CUSTODY IN A
CRIMINAL CASE IMMEDIATELY
DISQUALIFY THE EVIDENCE. EVEN
AT THE EXPENSE OF LETTING AN
OBVIOUSLY GUILTY INDIVIDUAL
GROCERY. CHAIN OF CUSTODY A
BALLOT IS NO LESS VITAL FOR A
FAIR AND HONEST VOTING SYSTEM.
UNRESTRICTED BALLOT COLLECTING
COMPLETELY REMOVES. OF CUSTODY.
SO BALLOT CAN NO LONGER BE
INSURED TO BE LEGITIMATE. THE
DOW. DONE ONLY ELECTION. BUT TO
VOTE TRY. AND CO. AS WE THOUGHT.
IF TO A FREE SYSTEM. SECOND ONE
FIVE. EIGHT AND ASK. THIRTY
FIVE I ASSUME THAT CERTAIN
TYPES OF ROW. BALLOTS ELECTION
ARE LEGIT. AND THAT OTHER ARE.
THE I. P. C. A. IT RIGHT.
ALTHOUGH IT'S WILL BE
LEGITIMATE AND FAITHFULLY
DELIVERED ON ALTERED FOR
PROCESSING THIS CAN ONLY BE
ACCOMPLISHED YOUR METICULOUS
CHAIN OF CUSTODY REQUIREMENTS.
EFCC URGES THE LEGISLATURE TO
REEXAMINE THE ISSUE OF THIRD
PARTY ABOUT COLLECTION RETURN
TO THE PRE AB NINETEEN TWENTY
ONE STANDARDS FOR THE
ROTECTION OF VOTERS. AND THE
INTEGRITY OF THEIR VOICE IN
GOVERNMENT IT SECTION ONE EIGHT
FIVE SIX STATUS REMOTELY DO
SUPPORT THIS BILL BUT WE WILL
CONTINUE TO URGE THE
LEGISLATURE. TO REFUND THE
LEGALIZATION OF UNRESTRICTED
THIRD PARTY ABOUT COLLECTION
FOR FUTURE ELECTIONS IN THE
STATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
WEISS. OPERATOR WE SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO LIST THEIR
NAME AND AFFILIATION. AND
POSITION. IN OPPOSITION SB
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU IF YOUR
IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AND WE'LL FIRST
FINE OF FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO THIS IS AMY CHAU
FACTOR COUNTY RESIDENT AND WITH
THE ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
IN CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB THIRTY FIVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NICE COLOR
PLEASE. THANK YOU THAT'LL COME
FROM LINE OF TWENTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I TWENTY NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS IS JEFF
BABSON I'M A PRIVATE CITIZEN IN
STOCKTON CALIFORNIA AYE OPPOSED
SENATE BILL THIRTY FIVE THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU COME FROM A LINE OF THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ROBIN DID
STAND WITH THE PEOPLE RISING IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. THIRTY FIVE
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THAT'LL COME FROM LINE OF
NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI THIS IS JENNIFER JOHNSON
PRIVATE CITIZEN PLASTER COUNTY
AYE OPPOSED SB THIRTY FIVE.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
BETTER COME FROM LINE TWENTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THIS YES
JOURNAL I THINK WHEN CORRECT OF
COLOR I ONLY OPPOSED THAT
MEASURE AT THAT LIMIT. THIRD
PARTY HARMS IN A BALLOT I THINK
THAT PEOPLE FEEL SAFER WHEN A
VERY MUCH HAS THE MONEY FOR SHE
HAD A VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE REMINDER TO YOU THAT'LL
COME THAT JUST TO GIVE YOUR
NAME AND AFFILIATION AND
POSITION IN OPPOSITION WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION SO JUST
PUTTING YOUR NAME ON THE RECORD
IS WHAT WE'RE- DOING NOW. THANK
YOU OPERATOR. THANK YOU WHAT A
LINE OF TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. LINDA ANDERSON
RIVERSIDE COUNTY OPPOSED SB
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER. BUT A LINE OF THIRTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. KIM EMERSON
FROM PLASTER COUNTY ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT I BELIEVE SB
THIRTY FIVE. THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WELL THE LINE- VIA LINE
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU CAROLYN CENTER
ALEXION INTEGRITY CALIFORNIA I
AM IN IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU THANKS
CALLER PLEASE. THAT'LL COME
FROM ONE OF SIXTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GEORGIA RIGHT
SOLANO COUNTY CENTRAL COMMITTEE
AND AYE OPPOSED SB. THIRTY
FIVE. THANK YOU NEXAVAR LINE OF
EIGHTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE MANDATORY PLASTER COUNTY
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION AS IT
STANDS. THANK YOU NEXT TO THE
LINE OF NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO DI<c.cyan> JOURNALIST</c>
ST FROM SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND I
OPPOSE. THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU
AN EXTRA LINE OF SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE RAIDER
RIVERSIDE COUNTY OPPOSE. THANK
YOU NEXT TO A LINE OF LINE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SUSAN
KENNEDY SAN DIEGO COUNTY OPPOSE
SB. THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU NEXT
ON THE LINE OF EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ALCHEMIC
TRONG SAN DIEGO COUNTY
REGISTERED VOTERS I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB. THIRTY FIVE. THANK
YOU RIGHT NEXT TO A LINE OF
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WHY INVEGA ORANGE COUNTY OPPOSE
SB THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU AN
ACTUAL LINE OF FIFTY TO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. VERY ALLEN
ILLEGAL OUT THAT MCHALE COUNTY
AYE OPPOSED SB THIRTY FIVE.
THANK YOU NEXT TO A LINE OF
THIRTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
**** ABOVE ENTER COUNTY
STRONGLY OPPOSED THIRTY FIVE.
THANK YOU AND ACCESSIBLE LINE
OF SEVENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. PAN BRADFORD ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT OPPOSE THIRTY
FIVE FOR ANY TYPE OF TALENT
HARPER STING. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE YOU. ALTHOUGH
LINE OF FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NAMPA MADISON INDIVIDUAL
AND RIVERSIDE COUNTY AYE
OPPOSED SB THIRTY FIVE AS IT
STANDS. THANK YOU AND NEXT TO
THE LINE OF TWENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CAROL ABOUT THAT
PLASTER COUNTY CENTRAL
COMMITTEE ABOUT SB THIRTY FIVE.
THANK YOU REMINDER WE'RE ON
OPPOSE ON SB THIRTY FIVE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AN
TO A LINE OF SIXTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. STEVE SHOW FROM PLASTER
COUNTY ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT I'M OPPOSED TO SB
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU THE NEXT
TO GO ONLINE OF THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. CALTRAIN WARDER
SANTA CLARA COUNTYI'M WITH THE
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT I'M
IN OPPOSITION TO SBTHIRTY
FIVE. THANK YOU AN EXTRA LINE
OF SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MANGED AFTER THEIR THEIR
PLASTER COUNTY ELECTION
INTEGRITY PROJECT TIME OPPOSED
SB THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU AN
EXTRA LINE OF EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MARLENA THE BRAIN
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY AND I'M
OPPOSED TO SB THIRTY FIVE.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF NINETY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CURRENT
RAIL SAN DIEGO COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE TRACKS.
THANK YOU FOR THE LINE OF
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CHRIS
FOSTER HUNTINGTON BEACH OPPOSE
SB THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU. AND
AS A REMINDER YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO IF YOU'RE AN OPPOSITION OF
SB THIRTY FIVE. NO NEXT ONE ONE
NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WHEN YOU REQUESTED FROM SANTA
CLARA COUNTY ELECTION INTEGRITY
PROJECT AND AYE OPPOSED SB
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU AND THE
LAST ONE AND YOU MISTER CHAIR
COMES FROM A LINE OF THIRTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
OPPOSE. SB THIRTY FIVE MY
NAME'S LETICIA CANALES LOS
ANGELES COUNTY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU OPERATOR WOULD
YOU GIVE A FINAL CALL FOR
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO LET THEIR- SO
INDICATE ON THEIR PHONE LAST
FINAL CALL OPERATOR. THANK YOU
IF YOU'RE NOT BUSINESS NUMBER
SB THIRTY FIVE YOU MAY PRESS.
ONE ZERO. ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. AND THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION IN Q. THANK YOU
OPERATOR AND THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR ALL YOUR GOOD WORK TODAY
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOING TO BRING THE- WE'VE
HEARD FROM SUPPORTERS AND
OPPONENTS OF GONNA BRING THE
MATTER BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR DISCUSSIONS
ANYBODY HAVE QUESTIONS OR
SUGGESTIONS. C. NINE A CENTER
NUMBER GOT THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL IT'S AN
IMPORTANT AND NECESSARY CHANGE.
TO PRESERVE THE INTEGRITY OF
OUR ELECTION PROCESS AND
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THIS AREA- AND WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE YOU TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN THANK YOU AND YOUR
STAFF TO GO AGAIN MR MONTHS
MODEL. FOUR YEAR CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS AND IMPROVEMENT OF
THE BILL. A COUPLE COMMENTS-
THAT THERE'S CLEARLY A
MISUNDERSTANDING AS TO WHAT
THIS BILL DOES LISTEN IN THE
OPPOSITION IN THE INTEGRITY
PROJECT MISS WISE. THIS BILL
DOESN'T DEAL WITH WHAT THEY
HAVE TERMED AS BALLOT
HARVESTING. THIS BILL DEALS
WITH VOTER INTIMIDATION.
PRIMARILY AT THE POLLING PLACE
BEEN TRYING TO FOOL VOTERS INTO
THINKING THAT OF FOR EXAMPLE A
DROP BOX IS AN OFFICIAL
DROPBOX. THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
DOES. UP IT IS SAID. THIS MAY
BE INDICATIVE OF MISINFORMATION
CONCERNING VOTING IN GENERAL
AND HOW IT UNDERMINES OUR
PROCESS OR SYSTEM. AND
DEMOCRACY I CAME TO PUBLIC
OFFICE BECAUSE OF A- INSTEAD OF
THE HAVE AN ORANGE COUNTY WHERE
FOLKS DRESSED AS POLICE
OFFICERS WERE POSITIONED IN
ORDER TO INTIMIDATE A NEW
CITIZENS IN THE EXERCISE OF
THEIR FRANCHISE THIS IS A VERY-PERSONAL ISSUE TO ME. AND I
THINK A PERSONAL ISSUE TO ALL
OF US THAT THEY CARE ABOUT THE
EXISTENCE OF DEMOCRACY AND
pAND I'VE A- TERRIFIC CAL THANK
YOU AGAIN CENTER I'M BURKE A
LOOKING FOR MOTION FROM THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR HERTZBERG IS
MOVE THE BILL. AND WITH THAT OF
THE CONSOLE WOULD CALL THE ROLL
THIS WOULD BE DO THESE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT SAYS SO
INDICATED AND THIS IS- DO
PASSES AMENDED WE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE. ON RULES. SB
THIRTY FIVE THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED AS AMENDED BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
RULES. GLAZER I LATER HI
NIELSEN. HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT
HERTZBERG AYE LEYVA AYE LEYVA
AYE NEWMAN ALL RIGHT NEWMAN
FIVE THE BILL HAS FOUR VOTES WE
HAVE A NUMBER MISSING- SO WE'RE
GOING TO PUT THAT BILL ON CALL
NOW. CHECKING WITH HIS
CONSULTANT. OKAY SO WE CAN
CLOSE THE ROLE OKAY GETTING THE
OKAY FROM THE MINORITY
CONSULTANT THAT'S OK CLOSE THE
ROLE THANK YOU CENTER NUMBER
GONNA CLOSE THE ROLE IN THAT
BILL THAT BILLS OUT FOUR TO
ZERO. I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF
YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
PLEASE- AND WE'RE NOT ABLE TO
TEST BY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING. TO THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS-
WHERE YOU CAN ABOUT IT FIND ALL
THAT INFORMATION AND PROVIDE
THAT INFORMATION TO US ON OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT WE
WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY
IN THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD.
THANK YOU AND WE THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
THANK YOU MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE'VE CONCLUDED OUR
AGENDA. THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS- IS OFFICIALLY A
JERK.
OKAY GOOD OKAY. YEAH THAT
MIGHT BE DIFFERENT I THINK YOU
FOR. YEAH YEAH OKAY THE BILL
HAS. OKAY RIGHT YEAH YEAH. OKAY
WHAT ALL IMPORTANT YEAH- RIGHT-
ON JANUARY FIFTH AT EIGHT YOU
ALL YEAH YOU.